une production du studio sf bio sans fil
de représenter parquet semi le podcast
on parle de ce qu'on veut nos invités
d'un titre du canton avec moi d'une
plante encore une fois chris milk
présente le podcast si vous voulez avoir
un nouveau caisse avec un design
original qui va vous représentez c'est
là que ça se passe
pour votre téléphone pour votre
ordinateur allez jeter un coup d'oeil à
ce qu'ils ont minutes
n'oubliez surtout pas dis-je d'utiliser
le code promo sans filtre pour 20% de
rabais et de cette façon là ils vont
savoir pressés nous qui vous envoie donc
c'est bon pour tout le monde cette
semaine donne un nom à la nature des
fois on reçoit des demandes des gens qui
veulent venir au podcast qui on ne peut
pas croire que tout ça arrive ou bt
j'arrête
j'aurais pu passer méthon avant pas très
bas de caste qu'un jour je jeu m'asseoir
et m'a serrée avec la pdg d'hydro-québec
pour juste jaser et pendant deux heures
c'est ce qu'on a fait une femme
inspirante
une femme d'une intelligence vraiment ça
crève les yeux que cette personne le nez
des gens super y en a qui sait vraiment
la rencontre est de parler de transition
énergétique avec l d'énergies
renouvelables de son histoire à elle
commet qu'elle ait commencé comme
étudiante en théâtre pour finalement
finir pdg d'hydro-québec à une histoire
qui a pas de bon sens c'était vraiment
un grand honneur et un grand plaisir de
discuter avec lui pour ce que je demande
c'est quoi son nom ce fibre fut
évidemment donc avant aller à la
conversation on va remercier le
commentaire merci le podcast de semaine
est présentée par emma point ca emob.ca
c'est une plateforme en ligne pour aller
chercher vos assurances vie si vous êtes
comme nous vous arrivez dans la fleur de
l'âge où est-ce qu'on commence à penser
à devoir protéger les gens qui nous
entourent nos êtres chers pour pas les
laisser dans le trouve si quelque chose
nous arrive est bien emma points 6e ont
pris ce concept là qui peut apparaître
comme effrayant ils ont simplifié pour
nous le rende accessible c'est que les
futures sur les mêmes points que j'ai
fait tout sera possible
c'est que c'est simple c'est qu' aucun
examen médical qui ne cessèrent on peut
le faire 100% en ligne sur la plateforme
hulu par téléphone ça prend 20 minutes
pour rester en pyjama et c'est réglé les
prix sont super bons sont super
compétitif c'est la vie c'est fragile
faut en prendre soin
on sait pas ce qui peut arriver car la
vie est si fragile
le glas la filiale active ça doit être
vrai pour ceux que ça prend une bonne
assurance vie comme emma possible mais
si vous savez pas exactement quelle
assurance est la bonne pour vous bien il
ya un support en ligne vous permettent
de mieux vous dirigez comme ça vous
allez pas payer trop pour quelque chose
n'avait pas besoin d'aller voir
exactement l'assurance que vous avez
besoin
tout ça dans le confort de votre foyer
quoi demander plus merci beaucoup m à
points sans merci
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
encore une fois par nos amis chez police
les rouliers c'est la saison des
déménagements qui titre déménagement dix
changements de matelas c'est quand la
dernière fois que vous avez changé votre
matelas pensez-y pauvres et puis la
réponse risque died ça fait beaucoup
trop longtemps c'est pour cette raison
qu'on est fier de s'associer avec pour
les slips une compagnie
sic fait ces matelas à morgat lé fait
que ça respecte l'environnement
considérant que cela va faire beaucoup
moins de chemin qu'est-ce qui pallie ce
livre nous propose d'autres mais
vraiment des berges et mac le c'est
tannant ses chiens c'est vraiment là une
des choses les plus chers les électro
feuilles dans l'escalier ça passe pas si
c'est pas évident à l'abattage des
polices lipsyc tomates l'ail arrive dans
un bois qui pas grosse qui c'est facile
à rentrer n'importe où sa boîte le la
livraison est gratuite pitot espère
rapide donc on commence ce qui vient
délivrer ce puits en plus tu t'ennuies
décès ça veut dire que si après un mois
de rencontres que pour une raison x lui
matelote combien pauvres ils viennent à
chercher aussi gratuitement puis a pas
de problème était remboursée à
l'intégrer le thé 100% mais en plus ils
reprennent le matelas dans le fond pis
ils font ils font pas juste leur passer
à quelqu'un d'autre travail des
organismes canadiens pour donner une
deuxième vie aux matelots financer aussi
drugs & cie terme au real
ils peuvent même délivré en vélo facture
a en plus c'est écologique et c'est le
fun c'est friendly en un code promo pour
vous si polis est-ce pour lisf j25 qui
voit dans description en dessous est ce
c'est du 28 juin au 19 juillet ça vous
donne 25 % de rabais sur tous les
produits par ici et s et voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
you say party on tourne
merci beaucoup d'être là merci à vous
deux avoue 3 de m'avoir et qui s'est
fait plaisir en honneur on pourrait
parler de vraiment plein d'affaires mais
je veux qu'on commence par je disais que
tu avais fait le conservatoire d'art
dramatique
comment est ce que quelqu'un qui fait le
conservatoire d'art dramatique devient
éventuellement pdg d'hydro-québec dans
sa carrière c'est quoi cette trajectoire
on parlait juste avant de rentrer en
nombre qui a pas vraiment de trajectoire
prédéfinis j'aimerais mieux compris
voyez pas quelque chose à comprendre
en fait moi c'est quand les gens me
disent c'est quoi ton plan qui rien n'y
en avait pas pied deux mois l'école ça a
été très difficile tout du long
je n'ai pas bonne à l'école j'étais pas
bien à l'école
qu'est ce qu'ils étaient qu'est-ce que
peu restrictif mais l'école les cris les
critères de succès de l'école et des
notes fait que c'est quelqu'un d'autre
qui établit le critère de ton succès
fêtes d'enfants on est tout gris rythme
notre vie à être le meilleur d'avoir la
meilleure note la meilleure note de ta
classe la meilleure note de l'école
l'amap c'est comme ça qu'on définit
hibon web avec moi j'étais peau j'étais
pas dans cette mouvance l'eau
j'apprenais pas comme ça enfin qu'au
lieu d'être la meilleure ou décider des
tuniques du facile c'est plus facile
puis fait le plus mal aux primaires
telles femmes parce que c'était au niger
nous amuse by lexus test est chouette
second stage a été une tristesse infinie
parce que je me suis remis dans un
couvent ans à l'âge de 58 ans les gueux
je n'ai pas partout la même place que
j'ai fait de 5,1 dans un coin jeu des
filles je trouve ça plate allemand parce
que moi je jouis digues ce que c'était
aller vu ça les vicois lévy puisse pas
parce que l'école et paul fanapi est et
je les aie des levées de fonds plus tôt
ils font un boulot remarquable c'est
juste pour moi construite pour être là
dedans
puis quand j'étais au secondaire en même
temps je fais le conservatoire de
musique et que j'apprenais la clarinette
mais je voulais apprendre le piano mais
chez nous il n'y avait pas de place pour
un piano à queue j'ai fait ça fait
faillite et elle concernant de musique
c'est correct mais bref j'étais exposé
indifférent à faire mais je me cherchais
beaucoup mais quand je suis arrivé au
collège de lévis le collège cellphone
d'abord j'ai rencontré l'homme de ma vie
me suis réveillé avec lui à matri plus
en plus celui-ci lui coûte félicite mais
ouais non c'est sa fête mais cet extrait
on n'appuie abandonné il s'appelle john
john travolta et uma roussillon t1 je
vous parle d'une bonne idée ça fait
j'allais faire les options théâtre avec
lui puis là il y avait et on avait deux
profs c'est denis bernard qui venait de
finir le conservatoire puis robert
lepage pour l'a 20 alors qu'ils étaient
les deux têtes pas connu de mai les deux
portaient ce qu'ils sont devenus
l'ex-petit magique
c'était extraordinaire ouais alors c'est
très fan en fait ce qui était le fan la
créativité un ph
c'est de côtoyer d'abord cette espèce de
compréhension de qui tu es et puis au
collège des 3 à 27,7 en premier
amoureuse et c'est l'avis de droit
j'ai vraiment le fort et clair je me
suis dit bon écoute ses fans se bouger
même exprimé je me suis rendu compte que
j'aimais communiqué puis j'aimais jouer
c'est le fameux théâtre parce que tu
joues un peu tu peux jouer hyper
méchante
titre tu peux tu éclaté entre colombes
histoires courtes décide de faire les
auditions du court ça va donc j'ai fait
le conservatoire pour le rendre compte
au bout de quelque temps que j'étais pas
une artiste
ah ouais après 10 km comment cette
réalisation le avait eu ben parce que tu
es entouré de deux vrais artistes de
gens qui sont prêt à crever pour leur
art lopy à l'époque au conservatoire
n'avez pas le droit de travailler fait
que ça les choix politiques créés dans
la douleur devant le droit de travailler
cinq ans et tous les effets leur percée
quand et au conservatoire du fait que ce
soit est dédié à 100 % du fait des
longues journées types ici comme une
petite bulle ultime j'ai vu plusieurs
amis qui l'ont fait qu ils font pipi
c'est vraiment sûr mais c'est encore
cette philosophie lieu de travail
acharné
ben j'ai des amis en théâtre mais aussi
en musique en fait le type les deux mots
justes sa musique c'était ça aussi
c'était si c'était paul topo la
discipline de fer de principe ceci
arrivera politique l'ex pas moi ça tu
vois piste et c'est seoul - les
religions je push au fait qu'on va
entrer en religion
alors longue histoire courte au bout
d'un an j'ai quitté conservatoire puis
ça il a jeté un peu à terre parce que tu
parle pas du conservatoire d'habitude
fait des économies et au consommateur
parce que c'est l'animal
[Musique]
parce que pilar écoute
ça remonte à quand même 40 ans lorsque
je te raconte mais c'était une époque où
on déconstruisait les gens n'ont pas
passé leur construisais leboutou il
manquait c'est qu'ils te laisse entre
les deux têtes être seule fille très peu
d'estimé avait pu quitter tu es tu étais
mal dans ton corps tu ne t'attendais
qu'un prof de reconstruisent puis le
conservatoire de québec a connu une
époque de suicide
alors je dis pas que ta cause du
conservatoire mais il reste que avec il
ya une jeune femme qui était dans
deuxième année de conservatoire puis a
décidé de tourner la vie puis je savais
qu'elle était dans cette période là
aujourd'hui pour personne qui me tire un
terrain mais c'est surtout que j'étais
pas une artiste mais j'aimais côtoyer
des artistes d'ailleurs aujourd'hui j'ai
des amis artistes paix chez moi quand on
est en droit de recevoir le samedi soir
il ya beaucoup de gens d'affaires puis à
+ moi y'a plus d'agriculteurs où il ya
plus de gens qui font plein d'autres
choses que de la business oui j'ai
quelques amis comédiens comme un coma
après on était en fait en fait là ça
fait plus on était partis ensemble mon
amour et puis moi avec le fallait que
j'étudie quelque chose plus aussi lui
non plus à la déconstruction c'était pas
pour lui non
il ya fait il est fait le stage de
l'école nationale en même temps que mon
choisir le stage à québec anyway écoute
une longue histoire mais après ça
j'avais aucune idée ce que je voulais
faire mais l'auto comme 18 ans qu'est ce
que je veux faire
puis d'ailleurs si seul système scolaire
et on embarque sur un tapis roulant pour
exposer sa voix en secondaire 3
t'appellerai de prendre une bière tapas
doit de construire une tour pas de droit
d'entrée des bas mais il faut tout 17 ce
que tu vas faire d'inviter un choix fort
un peu
six ans nature aussi en semaine à son
l'air trop inquiet il ya bien des
affaires qui étaient aucune idée c'est
quoi fait quand tu loges comme je savais
pas ce que je voulais faire je me suis
dit on va essayer quelque chose de
l'arche du fait que j'ai pensé
sociopolitique histoire économie aux
économies car en faire l'économie
j'ai fait économie encore là le bac ça a
été correct mais c'est qu'un jeu des
notes j'ai laissé ses cages j'avais si
je me disais jeu correct je vais
finalement bac b
ce n'est pas la grande passion le dépôt
j'ai trouvé ma vocation non non non non
non en fait plus j'avance et moi je me
disais que j'allais et économistes dans
la vie mais on avait des bons profs chp
ou choquer diriger la caisse pierre
fortin sipa économie ce qui est assez
connue au québec et ailleurs ça des bons
profs mais je je vibre et popi mais à la
dernière année du bac et on commence en
aucun droit dans la dernière année à un
cours optionnels le titre fort c'est un
petit gars du coup face à chose le fait
que j'ai choisi konami de l'énergie puis
le prof qui nous enseignait c'est un
syrien déjà à québec c'était très dur
antoine antoine ayoub puis lui tu
arrives en avant de la classe pour
n'était pas beaucoup parce que
visiblement l'économie d'énergie ça
faisait patrie p g ans il s'est assis il
y allume angie tendance car l'on fumé
trop cendriers urbains
puis le 6 mai nous parler de l'opep ont
maintenant atteint 2 des chocs
pétroliers
c'est qu'ils opèrent les grandes
compagnies de pétrole et ex bvp
l'échelle pourquoi il y avait été créé
plein les pays les
lee roy après s'être amené ce en
amérique lui parlait de la consommation
de pétrole cas précis parlait du budget
des familles et que je tombe en amour je
me disais ah ça c'est vraiment vraiment
une femme et que jj un grand coup de
foudre professionnel avec avec le
monsieur puis je finis mon copie ga
première de ma vie je décide de faire
une maîtrise mais je pense que c'était
maîtrise pas ce qu'il pense pas qu'il
dise madame brochet ou fait pau non je
commence avec moi je viens de trouver
quelque chose je veux les saisies là
j'ai fait un deal avec le le tic était
responsable du programme jeudi coûte
admettez mois jean 35 coupe si j'ai pas
autant mis cinq courts métrages or c'est
quelque chose qu'ils ont que j'aurais
aimé qu'on me dise avant parce que moi
aussi c'est avec un deal que j'ai
rentrant que je suis rentré en maîtrise
ok parce que j'avais pas me citer la
création littéraire qui me faisait
triper dans milk aux récréations j'avais
juste dix ans de plus puis dans mes
cours de com d'histoire de littérature
du 10 des classiques français ça
m'intéressait pas pantoute reja des
moins bonnes notes puis je suis rentré
comme seul en faisant indirectement la
preuve justement fait que ceux qui nous
écoutent ça se fait si vous avez pas les
notes pour rentrer en quelque chose
c'est pas il n'y a pas rien qui ait pas
une porte qui vous bloque le c'est
quelqu'un qui décide si oui ou non vous
entrez dans cette chose là est ce que la
plupart du temps ils veulent aussi tout
inscrire une session supplémentaire avec
c'est comme ça dans ta raison parce que
c'est toujours le aussi que qui s'est
aperçu que tu avais un talent pour la
négociation
écoute en fait je me suis jamais vu -
comme une négociatrice un mois je me
vois comme un commun une personne qui
crée des possibles avec ta quelque chose
en tête j'ai quelque chose en tête avec
si je gagne puis tu as perdu on a tout
perdu
si tu gagnes j'ai perdu ici rien fait
mais si tous les deux on est content de
ce qu'on a mis en place avec moi je peux
plus je me mets plus en mode création
quant aux négociations
quotatis qui très habité par ce je suis
habité par la créativité
je me considère pas comme une artiste
pascal artistes à quelque chose de plus
profond de plus ancrée moi je très
intuitive je ne fais de ventre je peux
je pour beaucoup dans la réflexion
profonde
c'est très ancrée sur une pensée riche
et nourrir tout une fille instant t mais
c'est la créativité quand même fait que
c'est ce qu'on fait on ne fait l'énergie
après ça la dernière année du bac
le prof me dit ottawa donne des débours
ch parce qu'on était un groupe de
ressources naturellement ta voix donne
des bourses avec la bourse était pour
aller en nouvelle écosse pour expliquer
aux pêcheurs les quotas de pêche
sauf à imaginer dans une cave en bord de
la mer avec leurs femmes voilées passer
l'été l'eau enfin comparé avec les
chiens et qu'on en arrive là bas puis je
rencontre un fonctionnaire le vendredi
qu'ils m'expliquent ce qu'il faut que
j'aille expliquer aux pêcheurs kingdon
une carte avec ses l'est du canada
pile des banques poisson là dessus ils
expliquent que lov les bancs de poissons
diminuent il ya moins de ressources et
donc il va falloir que les quotas de
pêche choix réduit plus vous expliquer
aux pêcheurs tout dépend bien sûr que je
peux y vivent de st
mais c'est la job agréable bourse comme
cette expérience était bien content que
c'est ok mais oui puis je pense que
j'étais naïve alors ça se passe sous sol
de l'église le dimanche soit la première
séance le dimanche soir j'arrive avec ma
carte
mais ce soit en espèces du train dans sa
vie avec la musique la guitare là aussi
je me sois sur le du train de la musique
des guitares puis nous tiendrait de
toute ma vie et que j'explique ça dans
mon anglais approximatif mais il était
correct les paniers puis la stricte des
monsieur bara qu'ils sont toutes les
deux gars une fille du québec qui
m'explique mon péché moins de poissons
en partant de cela alors là il ya un
monsieur qui se lève à pêcheurs qui se
lève et en arrière puis ils marchent
tranquillement pièce avec 48 et on
devrait dire car l'hymne à québec on dit
karaté qui arrive avec clermont
mon stylo feuilles j'avais un gros
feutre pour dessiner saint martory wa
fait que les envoie au large pour y
faire des pointillés fin de ligne
pointillée il me demande en engrais et
des ce que vous savez c'est quoi jeune
fille
ce nom et ça c'est la ligne des eaux
internationales
ok avec toi et des scènes deux bateaux
un petit bateau pas gros bateau là petit
bateau il ya un drapeau canadien dessus
et le gros bateau il met un drapeau
japonais soit cela dessine une fois fait
qu'il dit c'est ça l'enjeu mademoiselle
l'enjeu c'est que les poissons dans
trois cas au coeur de traverser la ligne
fait que si c'est pas moi qui le pense
et gros japonais qui va s'en aller avec
les voix contre 1 appelle chez
maupassant
je trouvais qu'il y avait un bon point
fait que la même après j'appelle
les yeux pour y avait pas eu appel à
témoin cci a raison mais il faut qu'on
faut qu'on diminue même classé comme rap
et parce que je te capable d'expliquer
des folies même puis john qui devait
enseigner le français à dalhousie en
quoi elle est en fait qu on sait ramener
mais l'on n'avait plus chaud on avait
brûlé les sous qu'on avait pour prendre
le traversier pour y aller aller plus
vite si on avait le chien mais quand on
est reparti et disons qu'on avait juste
assez pour mettre de l'essence dans le
tout puis il fait qu'on sera menée avec
avec le shin bet arrive il y était fin
juin poggia pad a pas un chien pas
d'argent je suis juif décision pour la
paix on a une gentille la soeur de
journée formidable a nous a accueillis
dans son salon avec le chien est clair
qu'il fallait pas rester longtemps de
toute façon on ne pouvait pas faire ça
alors là je me suis dit tiens j'avais vu
à nîmes istres et laval y avait quand
même ce tableau des jobs à faire mais
l'autre à fin juin il reste comme trois
feuilles etc là il y avait un boulot de
guide touristique selon louis je dis à
ta québec connaissait celui j'aime
beaucoup de musique ce que j'allais puis
telle exaspération
on est à saint romuald salam appelle sa
vie elle vivait je prends je prends le
temps puis l'a jeté un peu à l'avancé en
fait je te pas mal à l'avance je regarde
à gauche piste et crise occupe ce qu'il
s'occupe
j'avais déjà l'université c'est antoine
qui m'avait par des assassins
c'était une petite société d'état qui
s'appelait la société québécoise
d'initiatives pétrolières
à l'époque le gouvernement voulait
savoir ce qui est bien avec du pétrole
j'ai remis ça en place pour voir si on
veut quoi c'était dernier soin d disent
que ça avait commencé puis en fait de
l'exploration année oui alors je tiens
j'ai du temps je vois aller le mali
voire des coups puis je suis arrivé là
où je veux aller dans un bureau oui je
connais personne
voir vois je vois moi puis je suis
arrivé là puis avesnes y avait une dame
qui était l'autre qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour vous je devrais savoir la
personne qui engage le monde vous avez
vous un rendez vous je ne mange pas de
rendez-vous puits sur le champ
legault qui s'occupe des ressources
humaines sort du bureau en question
qu'il parte avant la réception samedi à
pierre justement mais jeune femme il y
avait un peu de temps j'ai fait une
longue histoire courte il devait
recevoir cette semaine la france est en
stage france économistes puis avait
décidé de faire son service militaire
je vous rappelle que c'était lui aux
calendes fekl l'oeil avait plus de
stagiaires a fait boum je suis rentré là
puis c'est comme ça que j'ai fait ma
carrière dans l'énergie est passé des
pachas parce que des pêcheurs ont décidé
que ça n'avait pas de bon sens que je
disais oui pascal france a décidé de
faire son service militaire puis pas
décidé de rentrer d'un bureau 15
personnes avaient demandé à wade je me
suis jamais rendu à l'entrevue de paris
puis m'a dit quand je vois parler avec
une coupe de personnes puis je te
rappelle en fin de journée je me suis
installé aux claques on avait été au
cinéma puis on va brûler le dernier les
derniers chocs on ne laisse pas un film
au clap
on note la maison qui m'appelait kim wan
de toronto jp tel match a tellement
je m'en souviens pas d'une bonne
question mais je pense que si je me
forçais un peu je le retrouverai député
salam députés en anglais ça je sais pas
saisi en france est l'un des pt s'est
trouvé quelque chose que tu cherches pas
ok ouais mais que tu espères que les
quinquas dur dur de penser qu'il ya des
fois les choses je crois pas au destin
est anxieux mais d'ici là de pratiques
défaut les choses salling pas haut comme
sur le petit somme que sam qu'il ya
tellement d'affaires qui mène vers un
moment comme celui là puis jusqu'à une
carrière complète c'est des petits
détails
en même temps j'imagine que c'est toi
qui écris un peu le train peu la chance
pour la france mais la chance c'est la
conjonction de l'opportunité de la
préparation
ouais 70 comme ça il ya une opportunité
que des preuves
ouais tu peux être près de la porte une
tv et paul l'opportunité de venir plus
t'es pas prêt total dans la grande
grande majorité des co la préparation
s'est juste l'ouverture de la curiosité
c'est moi je moi je juge porté par une
conviction c'est que on est on est en
effet pour ni construit deux mille vies
on pourrait faire mais la faim dans
notre vie mais on a une série de choix
qui nous amène dans un dessein donné
faut maintenant que tu as 90 ans tu te
retournes devant le mur de ta vie puis
de toutes les décisions de prises bon
alors à 12 ans j'ai pris cette décision
là j'ai décidé de faire du rock et p2
pour faire de ça que j'ai fait dur que
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un alors chaque y
de tes décisions de toute ta vie tu
amènes dans un coin mais aurait très
bien pu te ramasser dans un bon coup et
piquante 90 ans regarde tout le deal of
field
vie mais te regarde tout ce qui aurait
pu être si tu avais pris une autre
décision là tu dis ça aurait pu être
pleins d'à france ex pour ça que quand
quand je réfléchis à ce que je regarde
pourquoi j'étais pas bien l'école c'est
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'on me
destiné à choisir une affaire que
j'allais faire tout le temps je moi je
t'ai pas j'étais pas bien la danse tempo
était juste pas fonctionnel quatre
gardes le fils tu es le manteau de 90,1
m quatre gardes le fil jusqu'à présent
c'est sûr c'est eu un fils donc piqué
qui signifiait du bon d'achat
j'ai une fierté fierté je compte oui je
suis fier d'eux des équipes que j'ai eu
l'occasion de constituer
mais ça ça me rend vraiment fière ça me
rend fier de construit des affaires mais
je me dis j'ai contribué à quelque chose
soit je suis fier de ce mais je suis
surtout heureuse
gg puis c'est ce bonheur l'eau que
j'essaie je sais me donner des
conditions aux gens avec qui j'étais
raji d'être heureux dans ce qu'ils font
puis j'ai eu le bonheur d'avoir moi j'ai
eu deux patrons dans ma vie j'ai lu mon
patron chez ceux qui depuis mon patron
après chez g gaz métropolitain quand je
m'entraîne up si demain j'ai eu deux pas
trompé deux patrons qui étaient bien
avec des jeunes filles étaient très bien
avec des jeunes femmes qu'il n'y avait
pas de tv pas dangereux avec pour une
fille de ma génération c'est assez
unique
forexi j'étais bien fait que ce bonheur
que tout que tu ressens aujourd'hui il
était le tout au long
il ya eu des périodes au bail et des
perdants matin mes notes lors des jeux
demandez pas ça seulement il ya des
beaux staffs qui a des idées
il ya des fois où tu as des coups durs
tu marques davidoff
mais il reste que l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
est beaucoup plus exaltante pour moi
puis mettez en fait c'est là que c'est
là le bonheur d'apprendre c'est le
bonheur de 2 devrait si quelqu'un qui me
disait c'est quand même étrange sopheak
toujours une société des taux devrait
gérer d'autre chose qu'une société
d'état guy gaz métro ce n'était pas une
société d'état mais c'est un service
public jeudi
avec le recul aujourd'hui je capable de
nommer que pour moi le service public
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
parce que d'abord c'est ça que je posais
faire servir le public puis je trouve
que de travailler comprends moi bien la
lys où j'aime sur le capitalisme j'aime
souvent c'est pas l'idéal mais c'est le
meilleur système qu'on a trouvé en fait
j'aime toutes choses mais jusqu'où faut
que tu ailles pour avoir plus de tout
tout le temps alors que la grande
satisfaction vient pour moi de
contribuer à plus grand que moi
moi j'aime ça je comprends
puis quand tu côtoies carte arrive
m'attend chez hydro-québec août arrive
je garde métro mais même pendant
d'hydro-québec tarifs chez hydro québec
tu parles aux anglais qui sont dans la
rue les hommes les femmes les jeunes
sont servis saclay monde est fier c'est
sont fiers de travailler pour hydro
québec qui sont fier de travailler pour
ce fleuron la paix côte le 2 février
quand il feint de tempête de verglas
puis que les gueux qui les fait des
trous arrivait quelques amis on n entend
pas donnerait jeu puis quittera qui
raccorde lui cesser les coups d'amour
que les équipes reçoivent la population
puis la pandémie moi je pense nous ont
rapprochés de l'appréciation des des
services de proximité de ces sons sens
rahmani but
le karatéka qui a commencé dans ce
domaine le sait dans le domaine des
énergies fossiles principalement dans le
fond c'est absolument puis celle de plus
en plus le québec puis le monde il
toutes les sociétés c'est de se tourner
vers des énergies qui sont absents plus
renouvelable et verte ce que j'imagine
qui est que ce changement lui le vu
s'opérer le vraiment dedans oui premier
de front neigeux les vu s'opérer de
francs gelé vécu un gic ont couru puis
si tu regarde aujourd'hui énergie est
autant investi dans les énergies
renouvelables que dans la distribution
de gaz naturel
la description garda sur elle c'est pas
mal moins émissifs car les quais du
pétrole et du gaz au puy
c'est comme dans une entreprise où les
sens bien quand même des énergies
fossiles qui d'abord de voir ce
changement le ski est ce que c'est comme
ça qu'il faut y aller ou y est une
résistance ou c'est quoi ce sens ce
n'est pas qui tu parles c'est chez nous
chez à l'époque chez gaz métro
en fait on est parti d'un constat on a
dit on on distribue du gaz naturel
ce service essentiel pour le québec
beaucoup moins émissifs que la
consommation de pétrole
et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus
pour le québec
on était déjà au vermont puis qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire de plus chou vermand
alors c'est comme ça qu'on en a acheté
l'hydro-québec du vermont qui est une
quête et des entreprises
rien n'est pas coté en bourse pour les
devenu aujourd'hui énergie et le
propriétaire des infrastructures de
distribution de gaz naturel de 85% de
distribution d'électricité au vermont
n'y a pas de québécois loup à peu près
peau les gens du vermont fait l'idée
c'était un modèle de proximité
on s'était impliqué dans les énergies
solaire mais tu vois aujourd'hui je
capable de dire que l'électricité quand
les riches au québec en est restée pas
on est vraiment ça c'est de la chance
c'est de la géologie peu napoléon disait
qu'on avait la stratégie de sa
géographie
maintenant la stratégie de géologie est
aujourd'hui capable de dire que cette
extraordinaire mais tu es christ et peut
pas toutefois pas vrai ça coûte cher la
transition et qu'il faut qu'on mette en
place
d'abord tous les moyens pour consommer
le moins possible
ce qu'on consomme de la voir le plus
renouvelable possible puisqu'il reste
pas de prendre une énergie qui est la
moins émissifs possible exploit concept
on in japan avec des buts et soit plus
je les vois à l'ippj est en admiration
avec joe développe le gaz naturel
renouvelable 2 avec avec des
agriculteurs à saint-hyacinthe qui a la
plus grande la troisième plus grande
installation de biométhanisation au
monde avec sept points des déchets
agricoles des déchets de l'aide des
déchets domestiques des déchets de
restauration alimentaire le film soit
courte mais sans génie d'angers un
réservoir pour toi tu mets des bêtes là
dedans ça fait du gaz naturel qu'elle
injecte un ton réseau ça fait une
portion de gaza sur albert qui est
consommé au québec il faut pour écrire
presque naturellement très accéléré en
accéléré à partir de chez toi donc 7,7
ce que je sais mais je connais pas
beaucoup de choses moi mais l'énergie je
connais vraiment pas mais je connais
c'est ça pour savoir que l'intelligence
énergétique
c'est d'abord l'intelligence la
consommation comment je vois consommer
qu'est-ce que je vous consommez pas ce
que je vais faire attention ce que je
consomme bien précieux comme comme comme
eco systèmes énergétiques faut que tu
mettes une pléiade de moyens pour faire
en sorte que tu vas réduire des miss
gaz à effet de serre les full tilt face
au moindre coût possible parce que ça
coûte cher la transition on n'en parle
pas de show il ya un coût à la
transition puisque d'un coup qui est
bien inférieur à celui qu'on paierait si
on le faisait pas dans 5 ans 10 ans mais
un coup avec un coup que tu comprennes
que you un coup le studio autant
manouche il faut faut une voix y penser
comme fou comment on va faire se peut le
faire au moindre coup passé bien des
fois il faut que tu travailles avec
d'autres formes d'énergie c'est ce qu'on
a fait gabin qu'as-tu la pandémie tout
le monde s'est rendu compte que l'on
avait besoin d'eux de plus d'autonomie
alimente les gens dit ça nous prend plus
de ça bompard fait oui mes lectrices thé
chap ok qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
réduire tarif on ne peut rien de sorcier
chez hydro les gens une pense qu'on a
fait du vodoun pas du tout le jeu ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a pris le tarif
qui existait puis on a dit aux serristes
on veut le réduire
on va passer de 10 mettant ainsi 100
mais on va vous demander de garder vos
chaudière au mazout et aux programmes et
aux gardes assure elle pour qu'un on a
besoin un pointe
pascal lapointe dont ça coûte une
fortune fait que c'est juste ce qu'on
ait de la pointe
si je me rappelle de des enseignements
de rose son art 4 c en hiver mettant
dans les eaux vraiment précises ou sql
mettant le monde se réveille prennent
une douche d'eau chaude bichon leur déjà
mais c'est exactement et maman vraiment
ultra précis où est ce que leur ont
fourni pau ouest ont fourni mais si on
fournit ça coûte cher
ouais il faut construire des équipements
faut construire des lignes de
transmission faut construire des lignes
de distribution pour servais une période
des journées qui est très très
restreinte par n'a pas pris une certaine
d'apparat n'est tout le monde dehors du
monde juste extraordinaire on n'a rien
fait extraordinaire on a juste dit ok
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est de réduire
le tarif électrique pile
évidemment il voulait réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
sont s'était dit faut réduire toutes les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
j'aurais pété quart d'heure du rotary
qu'est ce qui se passe parce qu'il se
passe aujourd'hui on est passé de 10 à
plus de 1000 ses fils qui ont accès à ce
tarif là on développe l'autonomie
alimentaire on a réduit considérablement
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
parce que
autre la base et par sens d'électricité
mais ces quelques heures la la bonne
énergie en bonne place c'est pas
l'électricité
à défaut de quoi ça coûterait trop cher
mais ça moi je trouve que expliquer ce
qui se passe c'est tellement en
préparant pour pour la conversation
qu'on nous le dise que jusque je me suis
rendu compte en fait c'est que c'était
tellement compliqué c'est tellement
d'enjeux complexes qui avait pas de
solution simple typique les solutions
qui pourraient nous apparaître cinq je
mens comme tu mentionnes la transition
nous tiens qui peut dire une faisons la
transition faisons attention mais faire
la transition
c'est plus compliqué que le dire puis si
c'est si compliqué à comprendre je pense
pour eux mais pour moi le premier pour
tout le monde mais aussi des enjeux qui
sont ultra complexe qui est temps
d'utiliser l'électricité peut pas tout
faire
qu'est-ce qu'elle l'électricité peut pas
faire mais en fait tu vois l'électricité
aurait pu faire quand qu'elle ne peut
pas faire des fois c'est technique des
fois c'est économique que alors si c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle l'on parle
d'hydrogène je suis moi et iodée
l'électricité d'abord là ça fait virer
des motards sur l'électricité safran est
restée pour faire tourner le moteur
parfait les christie aussi peut servir à
l'éclairage l'électricité peut servir au
chauffage puis on a fait ce choix là
dans les années 80 chants des 10 au
québec que de sortir les fournaises à
l'huile puis d'utiliser davantage
électricité pour chauffer des maisons ce
qui était logique à l'époque puis qu'il
l'est encore aujourd'hui bien que les
plinthes électriques ce soit pour le
l'utilisation la plus efficace la
minustah l'auditoire
quand on la voit dans une usine doit
avoir parfois des grandes grandes
bouilloire pour les procédés industriels
mais pour chauffer des grandes quantités
d'eau ça prend de flandre il christ est
fait pas de plan mais que ça prend soin
de ma zone des mutants du gaz naturel
puis parce que le gaz naturel est
beaucoup moins émissifs pillés mais pas
de polluants bon
là il va y permet de se développer des
électrodes technologies mais s'il
fallait remplacer la flotte de gaz
naturel par de l'électro technologies
souvent ça soit pas possible
souvent ça va coûter trop cher quand on
regarde tout ce qu on a au québec comme
électricité
on est riche mais si on veut vraiment
décarbonés l'économie il va falloir
trouver quelque chose pour remplacer la
flamme soit ça s'appelle de l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène je te fais sausheim tu
prends d'électricité tu prends de l'eau
est un procédé qui s'appelle de
l'électrolyte place qui sort de soin
c'est un carburant
ça coûte cher ça coûte de moins en moins
chères pied ce qui coûte le plus cher
coûte cher les lectrices de elle est
restée puis la technologie le mail est
très important c'est l'électricité fait
qu si tu dis je m'en avait dans un monde
où l'énergie fossile devrait coûter de
plus en plus cher parce qu'on devrait la
taxe est ce sa note afin d'oeuvrer la
taxe évidemment politiquement c'est
difficile d'accès alors l'énergie
fossile devrait devenir de plus en plus
cher il va falloir la remplacer le au
québec en vain comme on passe à go 2 x
c'est que nos télés christ et et verte
fait comprend l'électricité verte
il en sort un hydrogène qui vers donc un
carburant qui est vert l'enjeu de ce
carburant le sait il faut tout le
transport peut transporter le stocker
c'est plus c'est plus instable que qu'un
autre qu'un autre qu une autre énergie
si tu veux faire la même affaire mettons
électricité tu as fait avec du gaz
naturel
outre le fait avec du mazout bâton
d'hydrogène et pas vers ce n'est pas en
train de vrd alors les québécois
vraiment un avantage inouïe parce que
d'abord on a déjà nous on ne déjeune
avec une transition énergétique quincke
robert bourassa en 1910 a dit nous
allons développer la baie james
quand il ya du sang arabe à bourassa et
son gouvernement s'était dit on consomme
beaucoup de
de là chauffage dans nos maisons dans
notre économie on n'est pas tant celle
hydroélectriques
il manquait just dance temps à l'opti
c'est une période qui était difficile
l'idée c'est à dire ben si on produit
net électricité au lieu de payer une
balance commerciale a d'autres qui nous
avons va se développer ça qu'on va se
payer ça nous mêmes cotes coup de génie
de mai il y avait une fronde but à
l'époque parce qu'elle écoute et on dit
on va développer la plus grande centrale
hydroélectrique souterraine au monde et
c'est encore la plus grande centrale
hydroélectrique souterraine au monde
c'est la moitié de ton énergie leur
explique la hérie la moitié de soutien
de la baie james spectre y avait ce coup
de génie là à l'époque les
considérations environnementales n'était
pas du tout ça à naples en plus du tout
d'ailleurs s'est posté step au chaud on
s'est découvert cette avance cet
avantage lots additionnels fait dans un
univers où il va se développer
l'hydrogène pour remplacer une flamme
mais le québec a déjà d'électricité
verte pour faire des l'hydrogène va ce
futur lieu à proximité
on est en train de construire un peu
partout à travers le monde puis au
québec en train de faire des pouilles
déjà de la production d'hydrogène
l'hydrogène ce pas une fin en soi c'est
un moyen d'un moyen de décarbonés son
économie mais c'est un moyen qui est
quand même coûteux puis qui devrait
coûter de moins en moins chers ou faire
mesure qu'on avance
puis les territoires comme le québec qui
ont une énergie renouvelable au québec
en plus elle est compétitive vont être
les premiers capable de faire cette
démarche
mettez au québec reste qu' on ne les
crises t on chauffe à l'électricité mais
nous comportement humain en est encore
très axé sur le pétrole
econocom en eux comme on est comme
habité par deux affaires n'est sûr qu'on
est propre au québec
pee wee en électricité extraordinaire
mettez la transition énergétique tout le
monde parle de technologie moi j'dis pas
une question de technologie
le livre est importante le plus
important c'est le psyché humain qu'est
ce que je vais faire moi comme un être
humain qu'est ce que je vois consommer
mais quand je parle de comportements
humains par le transport de tous ces on
utilise ou l'énergie fossile se pose pas
cela principalement la transporte en eau
qu en transe pas mettre là aussi
d'entendre dans ta consommation de tous
les jours oubli l'énergie que tu
utilises oublier l'énergie dirait que tu
utilises tu goût du café qui a fait
arriver parquet par l'agent de café tu
prends un café nespresso qui est qui qui
serait assez mal ou peu ou pas ou
maintenant tu prends un café qui tutoie
les ré étendant son compost après dans
ton jardin
je prends des notes je rentrais de nous
culpabiliser de toutes les décisions
qu'on prend ce qu'on achète ou tu
l'achètes d'où ça vient alors l'idée
c'est pas de dire on en est tout croche
faux chèques conscient et qu'à chaque
fois qu'on veut poser un geste bayonne
et un coup à ce geste löw qui après ses
7e et qui va payer
je vous donne un exemple très précis
parce que je trouve qu'ils simple dans
le désir de décarbonés la ville de
montréal
la mairesse madame plante a dit quelques
temps je vais ban et on nous allons
bannir les fournaises à l'huile de l'île
de montréal
bon tu dis 2030 ou moins chez flo
courait pas la raison pour laquelle il y
avait beaucoup de fournaise à l'huile
sur l'île de montréal
c'est qu'hydro québec avait encore un
tarif bi-énergie qui dit quand il fait
froid
quand on arrive à -12 site une fournaise
à l'huile qui embarque moi je vais te
laisser je vais débarquer l'électricité
parce que je vais utiliser pour des gens
qui ont pas d'option ça revient lapointe
dont je te parlais tantôt ou à défaut de
quoi
hydro-québec voka face des
investissements considérables pour être
capable de desservir la pointe de toutes
ces maisons aulas qui chauffé à l'huile
car on faisait froid puis tout à coup
ils chauffent à l'électricité
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
dollars qui payent ce légume nous
touchons m'ont fait mal en rien de celle
face de dire si nous on essayera gaspé
petit à gaspé il va tarifs électriques
kit un petit peu plus élevé parce que à
montréal
des carboni nos fournisseurs nous font
mal mais qui sont encore à l'une chez
eux
du coup je dis pas que ces banques c'est
mauvais c'est correct
il faut jeu d voici ce que ça coûte
l'impression qu'ils paient ça reste une
vision comment dire dans l'immédiat je
comprends qu'il gaspille peut-être que
dans l'immédiat te dérange pas mais tant
qu'on pense vraiment et un environ 6,6
venant d'iran mentalist soit auto
d'attac dirais oui mais les prochaines
générations dans 50 ans d'enfer
il faut il faire il faut le faire mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour aider les
jeunes gays espère réduire leur
consommation d'huile je sais pas alors
le point le point la dass et il n'y a
pas de d'abord il faut pas démoniser
personnes faux-pas de démoniser les
énergies faut juste se dire ok on va
avancer
pis si individuellement en avance
collectivement on va avancer plus il ya
des joueurs comme hydro-québec comme
d'autres qui vont dire qu'ils nous
envoient on faire un poids-lourd
important pour faciliter telle ou telle
transition
mais cette mais c'est pau c'est pas
simple c'est plus simple un petit peu
plus un peu plus tôt quatre parler des
des pointes justement type c'est
justement dans certaines poindre on va
utiliser encore le gaz naturel pizza
faut l'expliquer aux gens j'imagine
qu'ils aient une partie de la raison
pour laquelle tu est ici aujourd'hui ici
parce que il ya peut-être soit l'opinion
publique envers des sur les énergies
fossiles ou hydro québec en général mais
ton si on compare avec hydro québec il
est l'homme le l'idée qu'ils étaient
hydro québec au début puis l'espèce de
teint projet quitté key qui à l'époque
ce pas reporter puis le château fut
rapide est ce que fait une question
est-ce qu hydro québec avec les temps
pour éplucher les jeunes est-ce que ça a
perdu un petit peu de son son blason
puis c'est ce qu'ont kiki votre mission
en fait d'essayer de redorer wima écoute
si j'ai un chouette moment mon rêve mon
utopie là ce serait que tous les jeunes
du québec quand ils finissent au savon
mon temps aux travailleurs baie-james
aller s'asseoir avec l'écrit iam annick
aller converser avec les et nous c'est
allé voir ce que c'est puis de se
rappeler de se rappeler parce
qu'aujourd'hui situeront dans son studio
là tu fleix que la lumière dans les
mythiques trop laborieux qui se prend
pour acquis
puis on oublie qu'on a le tarif
résidentiel le moins cher en amérique du
nord
c'est en groupe et huit nations unies si
tu t'en vas new york si l'événement
s'intitule aucune aucune commune mesure
avec on prend on prend toujours pour
acquis puis je dis pas que les jeunes on
le réalise pas c'est juste qu'ils ont
pas est exposé à la même mouvance
historique
aujourd'hui le hydro québec c'est à toi
c'est un mois ça nous touche c'est pau
c'est quand on est au gouvernement je
l'aimé avec ce système nous c'est notre
maison
d'abord je veux que tout le monde des
jeunes aux plus vieux s'approprie ckoi
hydro québec chez qui je sais qu'on fait
puis on fait ça comme un fait avec
avec ces camps tarifs chez hydro loeb et
je peux en parler avec beaucoup de
distance parce que je peux de propriété
la jarrie l'uzège encore une rookie chez
hydro québec
mais qu il ya de l'intelligence il dit
ladd de la passion des expertises
diverses aux pieds carrés entre pologne
je vous donne un exemple on voir
l'électricité sur le marché spot aux
etats-unis nous donne un exemple de ce
que je suis bon lectrice this pour le
christ et le sas base sas va alors ça se
vend 1 journée ça se passe mais l'oeil
manaia de l'énergie solaire s'est
développée aux états-unis jeu c'est
super on est content mais là on a des
gens qui font de la météo des
météorologues chez nous les regarde
il va te faire froid votre fer chaud
avocettes humide puis l'a couvert
nuageux on était les premiers modéliser
ce en amérique la modélisation des
couvert nuageux et les nuages vont
passer la fête les centrales solaires
dans nouvelle angleterre fonctionneront
pas été loin
bonne idée c'est une mini lunettes tu
arrives sur le parquet te regarde solo
ses preuves à new york l'a annoncé c'est
extraordinaire après ça tu t'en as voit
dans le nord puis tu regardes les ce qui
a été construit
tu tu vois comment avec l'écrit on ne
reconstruit les territoires de pêche
territoire de chasse les maîtres de
trappes est tout content c'est extra
mais quand c'est pas ces porcs est pas
parfait hydro-québec loin de là mais à
l'époque les relations aujourd'hui
j'imagine son meilleur mais ça peut
toujours eu quelques meilleurs sont pas
parfaits
il nous reste beaucoup de chemin à faire
mais on parlait de de robert bourassa
qu'un robert bourassa sont dédiés cela
dit on on va développer
en fait il ya en fait y'a pas il y avait
oublié un appel fait quand est arrivé là
les critères ayant découvert soit bien
dit over our body à lyon a pris ce
kansas pas radio tient alors quand les
employés les ouvriers sont arrivés
là-bas le la chicane a pris la bataille
prix ça a été l'enfer les tribunaux
autorités çà et là les tribunaux ont
forcé une conversation entre le
gouvernement du québec et les cris qui
ont dit en instance d reconnaître notre
territoire
puis les yeux lisa entente entre le
gouvernement puis les cris qui ont donné
lieu à des ententes a pressenti d'euros
québec qui l'écrit ce qui fait peu après
sa peau toujours été rose
qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a
des relations très partenariale avec les
cris parce que le gouvernement reconnu
les droits qu'ils avaient sur scène leur
territoire
certains des territoires du côté des
inouk cette reconnaissance la halle pas
encore été fait ni par le fédéral n'est
par le provincial alors qu'il a mené qui
a été développé sur les sur les tarines
ou sur les dents les communautés et nous
alors aujourd'hui il ya une blessure
dans cette communauté locke et des mails
côte
vous êtes chez nous vous produisez une
récente chez nous puis j'aime ce qu'on
reconnaisse le territoire hydro-québec
pour reconnaître des droits on ne
possède capacité la mer on peut faire
beaucoup mieux pour redonner à la
communauté
moi c'est ce qu'ont fait fait le con
autres ce qu'on a 1 2
de mes grands bonheurs récent le en
arrivant chez hydro c'est d'avoir remis
sur la table à dessin finalement convenu
d'une entente avec les communautés et
nous pour un projet éolien qui s'appelle
ap huit ape identique se prononcent pas
le projet implique est un projet éolien
que les i nous en ont rêvé pensée
développée pour installer chez eux puis
hydro-québec a grandi drogué mais va
être à clientes des communautés innues
ben moi je trouve ça formidable
est ce que c'est ça le futur
d'hydro-québec plus les alliés puissants
là plutôt que quelques et
l'hydroélectricité compteur mais regarde
c'est pas une question de plus tôt que
c'est les deux ensembles piste explique
parce que l'éolien pitch solaire
l'éolien surtout le court beaucoup
diminué fait que le coût est rendu très
concurrentiel mais ce sont des énergies
qu'on appelle un intermittent eelv à
nantes pas tout le temps cette vente
porte au pôle énergie qu'en s'y fait pas
tant qu'artiste accable oui mais le
stockage c'est les réservoirs
hydroélectriques de ces comprends vous
balancent des grosses batteries le des
batteries et des batteries ion il faut
juste penser qu'une batterie par des
petites batteries pour une heure des
plus grosses batteries pour métier pour
des batteries sur des parcs pour
absorber tu pourrais pas je pourrais pas
avoir toute une économie jeu sur des
batteries de l'éolien pizza strict des
centrales aux états unis à gaz naturel
et au charbon et au mazout
parce que ça prend de la base
hydro-québec nos réservoirs l'évoquent
les mines mais ceux qui nous écoutent
c'est la base constante c'est la base
constante qui est là puis kir mental qui
monte qui balzac l'hydroélectricité
c'est pour ça que la laj aux canaux avec
les voisins ou américains on leur envoie
d'énergie mais lorsqu'on leur dit c'est
écoutez développer votre énergie
éolienne votre énergie solaire votre
énergie renouvelable à vous pour vous
verte et puis quand ils voient entrepôt
qu'il fera beau soleil et l'envoûtant on
va vous en vendre de l'énergie aussi
fécond
c'est ce qu'on appelle la batterie du
nord-est américain expo reçoit que notre
cerveau est fait on est bien quand on
simplifie les affaires mais l'énergie le
cpo simple hockey qui s'est pas pour eux
c'est pas parce qu'il faut être
intelligent pour comprendre c'est juste
qu'il faut comprendre
il faut mettre une pléiade de moyens
pour arriver à ce puits dans ces moyens
là j'imagine que là j'oublie le terme
mais pas la conservation d'énergie mais
la pièce d'efficacité énergétique
j'imagine que ça fait partie de cette
lettre de moyens le plus important
d'être capable individuellement d'être
bien individuellement et collectivement
d'être plus efficace avec notre énergie
d'entre eux contre ishop maîtrise pas ce
que ça passe principalement par les
formats mentalité plus que par
l'innovation
les deux savent et les deux parce que
souvent l'innovation en fait parce que
tous les gens si on a un but ultime
étant maintenant le début le 15 mai
moins d'énergie si j'échoue entre les
deux cycles trek va prendre ce sujet
parler des plinthes électriques
si on ne sait jamais plus efficace ma
maison je le prendrai peut-être toi
alors nous on a d'abord l'efficace
énergétique là c'était un truc
personnellement en quoi je crois depuis
longtemps puis hydro québec y croit
depuis longtemps mais à l'époque on
était on était chez gaz métro quand on a
lancé le programme d'efficacité
énergétique ont été les premiers en
amérique du nord en distribution d'un
intérêt à ce que les gens disent vous
êtes fous êtes en train de vous tirer
dans le pied
mais quand je reviens à ma nation de
service public chez georges est tantôt
c'est le boulot c'est de raccorder le
plus de clients possible après soit des
aidés à consommer le moins possible de
ce qu'on leur puits hydro québec quand
tu mets ça à l'infini si on veut
décarbonées puissent amener vers
l'électricité des charges qui
aujourd'hui sont servis avec des
énergies fossiles
mais si on continue de consommer
beaucoup chacun nous on sera pas capable
d'en prendre ou si on les prend le lit
tarifs vont aller
true d'euros ils vont atteindre des
sommets si tu veux garder des tarifs
concurrentiels pour peaux abîmées ton
économies pour t'assurer que tu restes
avec des coups qui ont d'ailleurs pour
le manga qui chauffent leur maison et
tout mais il faut que chacun nous en
consomment le moins possible puis il
regarde depuis 2002 mais en 2004 puis
2020 les mesures d'efficacité
d'énergétique qu'on a mis en place puis
que tous les québécois dégager ces dix
stars à water térawattheures c'est quoi
c'est l'équivalent du contre qu'on a
signé avec le massachusetts
je sais depuis 2000 cas en 2004 puis
2020 puis là quand on regarde devant
deux autres là on va doubler nous sûrs
dans les prochaines années
c'est des centaines de millions qu'on va
mettre là-dedans parce que ça nous coûte
les mesures qu'on met pour ta et des
lots t2 tu veux changer quelque chose je
vois tu as aidé je vois de subventionner
ça ça va nous coûter 300 kilowatts heure
mais si je mettais pas 300 kilowatts
heure faudrait battre cht désir lien
vraiment dit ça déclenche des lignes
électriques tout le kit avec 300
kilowatts heure c'est ce que je vais te
donner pour isoler sa maison que je
savais que le gouvernement cache du jeu
l'on parle de l'écosystème là rien à
voir avec moi l'écosystème va de t d est
équipée à avoir des équipements plus
efficace taffournay la reva durée de vie
utile on va te mettre une fournaise qui
peut être plus efficace on va donner 300
kilowatts heure parce que nous jouerons
voir un coût évité de cesser samedi et
ça c'est super important parce que si on
manque l'efficacité énergétique la
transition énergétique je vous le dis on
est au québec les galeristes et et peu
cher mais si on n'est pas capable de
mettre des mesures d'efficacité
énergétique on l'a réussi repos ça va
coûter trop cher
puis la consommation et dessus à un
croissance constante à consommation
d'électricité en fait la consommation
d'énergie en feu la consommation
d'énergie
fébrile à peu près à 1 2% si tu regardes
1 2% par année la place qui s'enlise la
transition énergétique cette transition
l'ol elle fait en sorte qu'il ya des
créneaux qui vont consommer qui
consommaient pas l'électricité pour les
voitures par exemple est loin d'être une
nouvelle demande
ex pour ce que ont de tout ce qu'il faut
au québec mais il faut comprendre
il va falloir qu'on priorise piquant pis
pour moi la mesure c'est comme il ça
coûte la tonne de gaz à effet de serre
éviter ceux d'une mesure j'ai des points
de mesure ça coûte 100 piasses attendent
de gaz et vu mon soutien et nous qui
coûte 500 pages web
je veux en faire un paquet qui vont
écouter ça avant de faire c'est la saint
sang mais peut-être que c'est la 500 est
très politiquement attrayante par
exemple les subventions véhicules
électriques le cepos et ça coûte cher
la tonne de gaz à effet de serre éviter
mais tout le monde en veut
puis tout le monde aime ça c'est facile
à expliquer mais ce qu'on a besoin de
faire plus que des véhicules c'est des
transports publics
et puis les élus le véhicule quand le
soleil treacle il ya une empreinte
écologique le fait de l'acheter pour
construite en ski le transport en commun
stehly c'est facile parce que là où ici
on est à montréal pc qui au total ont
ils des transports en commun on la met
fait juste traversé le pont puis
expliqué
à écoper l'eau qui ont deux enfants que
là ils devraient pas avoir de véhicules
puis devra aller travailler puis alioua
ok pas les promener les enfants leur
coupe suffit de faire ça notre but
c'était une impossibilité absolue le nom
indices où on le pas il l'est pas alors
on les des manises repos mais quand tu
regardes promène partout en il ya deux
véhicules par maison pourquoi pas y ait
ici c'est intéressant ce pourquoi il ya
deux véhicules par maison l'autonomie
des parrains individuellement mais en
fait tu regardes bien moi j'ai une
théorie ça à pied la théorie c'est la
suivante il ya des années le
gouvernement a fait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et ont dit on va mettre
en place un système de garderie mais qui
serait va permettre aux femmes d'aller
sur le marché du travail est d'aller se
développer puis d'aller au bout de leurs
ambitions professionnelles
tout le monde a cru dessous c'est
extraordinaire d'ailleurs le québec
aujourd'hui quand je regarde le reste du
canada
c'est ce qui est le gouvernement trudeau
est en train de faire un système de
guerre de vie est très les femmes on
commence à travailler merveilleux
qu'après sol et les entreprises on dit
maintenant on va faire la conciliation
travail famille et quand vous vous
donniez des horaires variables
oui c'est parfait en donnant des
horaires variables les caisses qui se
parle c'est un couple maintenant un
couple de deux femmes de 2 go ou d'une
femme porte un couple le matin vous
allez porter des enfants garderie salle
afin qu'ils vont aller chercher soi on
ne soit pas ce même en rafales qui ont
deux autos à la race car sinon ça dure
un an je sais qu'ils facturent à jeu
papa à ta ville
c'est impossible c'est impossible à la
laune et à montréal puis ça nous
apparaît évident mais au lac saint jean
dans le bas-du-fleuve fiche il n'y en a
pas on fait juste à québec le québec et
qu'il qui est une grosse ville aussi le
québec t'imagines québec sans voiture
c'est impossible mais le problème par
contre si josée legault en région ou les
le fermier qui est un pick up je faisais
je comprends qu'ils aient besoin d'un
pick up le pij pas entre entre qui
devrait pas avoir un pick up mais par
exemple qu'en mettant à québec on essaie
de développer des projets de transports
en commun comme le tramway piquionne
résistance je me dis il ya quelque chose
d'aussi l'éducation à faire parce qu'ils
aient clairement il ya des gens qui a
manié les habitudes sont des habitudes
parce qu'ils sont des habitudes ne plie
pas parce que ce puits se trouve pas en
commun comme à québec sur le projet
comme ceux ci mais ça me semble juste
poussé ouais mais en fait c'est pour ça
que je dis ailleurs il ya dans la
transition énergétique
il ya la technologie et à l'innovation
pire l'être humain que l'être humain et
moi je démonise rit jamais personne mais
on a on a besoin de se conscientiser
puis de comprendre qu'il ya un hier coup
assaut les courses je te dis yellow le
coup fait qu'il faut il faut il faut le
nommer perd même temps on est habité de
dichotomie tige
j'ai un collègue qui est drôle il
souhaitait du mois matrice promène
partout que sa paille en bambou à
prendre des douches d'une heure à
l'autre et se fait chier on écoute et on
fait avec on était constitué de ça alors
c'est joli comme hymne à acheter mais
mais mais c'est ça donc on voit on va on
va progresser comme société le transport
en amérique du nord incluant le québec
c'est quelque chose qui est très ancrée
dans nos habitudes de vie pilote je veux
pas démoniser personne mais pour prendre
la pleine mesure de l'ampleur quand les
écoles sont ouvertes
quand les universités sont ouvertes
cégep sont ouvertes je t'envoie dans les
stationnements puis je regarde qui sort
des voitures le matin ne sait pas tout
des profs non non c'est sa valeur fut
bon voilà c'est une des raisons c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas encore les
transports en commun c'est quand on dit
il faut électrifier les transports en
commun à montréal ça fait de change mais
au lac-saint-jean tu veux pour
électrifier transports en commun tu veux
des transports en commun
puis s'ils sont au diésel ça va être
encore bien mieux s'il ya des bons
transports en commun que pas de
transports en commun
et si d'aventuré capable d'électrifier
certaines lignes parce qu'une densité
qu'il permet mais tu le feras un projet
de bus électriques et à chicoutimi s'est
posé peu viable il faut fauteuil de la
densité qui regardent votre parler des
han
mais je vais vous donner un exemple à
montréal montréal hockey parce que on de
plus l'orientation montréal c'est bien
correct d'électrifier nous transporte un
étui de transport très bien transports
en commun et là on dit ça nous prend des
autobus électriques me prendre un bus
électrique et le gouvernement peut
donner qui le gouvernement subventionne
enlisé lâchant des autobus urbains
parce que ça se paye pas juste avec des
tic est là que les gens paient pour en
parler dans les autobus bon alors
ouvrons lundi à partir de telle année je
ne financerait plus des autobus qui ne
sont pas électrique
tout le monde est extraordinaire on
reçoit des autobus a décrit un crime
parfait
ça change un peu la vie des autobus
électriques mais parce qu'il a fauté
recharge
alors pendant pendant longtemps le
jusqu'à il ya quelques mois le modèle
d'alimentation des autobus électriques à
montréal c'était le biberon nage le
bieber nage comme biberon une alors
autobus avance puis un certain certaine
cadence à certaines stations
ils arrêtent un petit peu plus longtemps
pour recharger puis continue je
rentrerai pas dans le détail parce que
je le comprends pas mais on ne réalise
et les gens qui travaillent la norme la
zik ça marchait pas et donc qu'il
fallait revenir au modèle où on charge
les autobus la nuit dans les garages non
plus de remettre des bornes
ipalle intelligente fait l'autobus
bécavin qui arrive la banque va
reconnaître que c'est l'abbé 40
il va voir qui reste 12 % de charge puis
qui s'en voit dans un trajet x2 même si
je proviens de leurs charges au complet
parce qu'il va revenir puis ford
entretient on voir la borne qui va faire
semences correcte des petits coups c'est
quand même et là les gens se rendent
compte de quelque chose d'assez
fondamentale ya pas de garage à montréal
qui est capable de gérer ce il faut
construire des nouveaux gardes
des nouveaux garages lancé des centaines
de millions demandés vos musiques hockey
qui bâtit les garages qui paye les gages
ça coûte combien les garages c est ce
que c'est le ticket de transport en
commun qui est ce que ça devrait être le
gouvernement qui paye pour ça parce que
ça devrait des taxes à ce que allah mon
point c'est peu de dire qu'il faut pas
les cris fier c'est qu'il faut qu'on
soit humble collectivement [ __ ] on va
essayer d affaires on va avancer
il va avoir un coût va falloir qu'on le
sache on pourra pas tout faire en même
temps pour la con priorise avec ses pots
simple c'est fou parce que tu dis mais
il rien n'y a rien de cinq ans que je
comprends cet avis finalement c'est un
quart partant toutes ces variables d'un
bonheur parce qu intellectuellement
c'est fascinant puis c'est pas moi qui
fais autobus et bons mots que le
chargement mais je note rôle à nous
hydro québec d'être un catalyseur de
possibles c'est ce que ce soit comme ça
alors c'est que veulent les gens puis
que peut-on faire pour aider ce rêve là
qui pourrait aider pour savoir de quoi
on pas il faut calculer et moi je crois
au chief puis si elle veut poser que
parce que quelque chose comme ça qu'il
faut pas le faire parce qu'il ya des
affaires qui coûte cher il faut faire il
faut le savoir ce que ça coûte
il faut dire au monde ce que ça va
coûter payer puis qui va payer paul pour
avoir parce que si on dit rien dans dix
ans va se ramasser avec des tarifs
électriques qui vont coûter une fortune
plein des gens vont d'eux mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé si on le jardin des
lectrices vous l'avez lu c'est alors
donc on va le dire on travaille ça se
fait ça ce fait la trace a pu se faire
la transition énergétique au québec on y
croit on de l'énergie peau mais il faut
mettre une intelligence humaine
l'intelligence humaine c'est pas celle
d'hydro québec s'il celle des millions
de québécois qui m'ont dit ok s'en va
faire son ensemble s'en va le faire plus
tard sa wii va y avoir un coup puis on
va l'assumer a fait serait ce que le jeu
avance une solution puisque le ring un
sport qui connaît sa vie si tu vis oui
c'est à 22 ans elle sait on leur souffle
un couple de semaines
jean martin forte il était agriculteur
bio de seppi qui lui prône le local puis
aussi beaucoup la proximité puis
l'autosuffisance dans un sens est-ce que
l'énergie c'est une avenue
l'autosuffisance à partielle mettant le
ticket pipi pourquoi on ne paut des jeux
tout des panonceaux la sni toi tu mets
ton personnel est resté coûtera huawei
et même si les tarifs des tarifs
électriques le moins cher en amérique ne
le motive mon petit panneau pire mais
non bah tu peux mettre des panneaux mais
gmail mais votre lectrice et votre côté
de chats que c'est être connecté à
hydro-québec fait que je dis est ce que
je pouvais pour l'heure pas parce qu'il
faut que tu l'instar du pain ou le super
est un des panneaux c'est sa [ __ ] en
panneaux installés
gérez votre côté de chaque s'étaient
connectés sur hydro québec alors voici
ce que ce qui va se passer à mon avis ce
qui va se passer à mon avis c'est qu'un
jour il va y en avoir des panneaux sur
les maisons puis un jour il va y avoir
des batteries dans les pieds on le fait
au vermont dans mon ancienne vie
d'intrus dans les maisons des batteries
dans les maisons dans des quartiers
hockey des grosses batteries qui vont
être posées l'électricité je vous
parlais de lac-mégantic tantôt mais ça
plutôt que ce soit une décision de
dominique ou une décision de ph de
mettre un panneau puis de payer seuls
puzzle de le raisonner en modèle
d'affaires sur sa stricte maison on va
le faire et donc avec on va le faire
avec toi ph - le fer avec toi dominique
puis plutôt que d'avoir un panneau pour
une maison
peut-être qu'on va avoir dans un
quartier dans une communauté au delà du
système hydro électrique québécois des
des panneaux solaires avec des batteries
pour accroître notre économie encore une
fois on va mettre en place pour chez v
pour écrêter lapointe se soit pas que la
pointe nous coup de chalut lac-mégantic
vous savez ce qui est arrivé là il fallu
reconstruire la ville dont le réseau
électrique alors hydro-québec colmar
construit le réseau électrique comme
celui que vous connaissez traditionnel
connecter sur les grands lignes de
transmission mon 6 et tant qu'à faire on
voit on voit installé au lac mégantic
toutes les innovations technologiques
qui nous arrive
on va mettre des panneaux on va mettre
des mots dessus on va mettre des
batteries on va voir comment tout ça au
père quand on quand on ferme par exemple
système d'hydro-québec
parce qu on simule un grand verglas
comment ça réagit qu'est ce que c'est
capable d'alimenter en vie on était en
train d'opérer
alors demain demain en fait aujourd'hui
l'électricité vote du nord au sud on
produit est basé à magny-cours au projet
bois n'at-on pas d'électricité
sas a embauché clients demain matin
chacun de nous allons être des mini
barrages des mini relire des mini parce
que d'abord on va consommer moins donc
on va libérer l'énergie hydro qu'après
avoir des outils qui vont faire en sorte
que chez moi je dois être capable de
repousser l'électricité sas europe c'est
sa voix est assez bien tôt ou tard
voiture électrique pour être capable de
pousser d'électricité et d'eau québec ça
on en a besoin parce qu'avoir été chargé
pas partie je m'honore de besoin mais la
sauce tout ça c'est des innovations
technologiques c'est tout
c'est là dedans qu'on n'ait pu moi je
vois des têtus parlent et de la fierté
des jeunes on vient de lancer une
initiative qui s'appelle énergies en
commun
on a dit on le fait chez nous avec nos
employés avant de le faire là mais là on
est lancé on a discuté on veut savoir ce
que vous pensez
voici trou au thème l'autonomie
alimentaire l'économie verte
l'efficacité énergétique qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce cap on a un sondage
puis à faire lundi
si jamais vous avez des idées le
partager aux disciples votre rêve qu'est
ce que tu aimerais de quoi que tu besoin
on s'est dit on va en avoir deux trois
mille je vous parle amateurs ne pas
encore fini nos 6000 de rentrer conseil
me l'idée de partout au québec
puis ce que j'aimerais c'est kate plus
de jeunes de 16 à 25 ans qui rendent des
idées on en est à peu près 18 % des
idées des jeunes que 10 des traits
simples comme écoute moi j'aimerais ce
savoir si quelqu'un travaille sur têt la
face comme je travaille sur telle
affaire puissiez vous pouvez mettre en
contact des enfants 13,5 nadeau qui
disent bien nous autres noté merci on
aimerait savoir davantage d'autonomie
alimentaire comment vous pouvez nous
nous faire une une innovation ouverte
sur l'autonomie alimentaire des séries
dans notre coin du monde il fait un peu
froid bonté on sera pas capable de tout
faire mais ce qu'on va être capable de
faire on veut l'appuyer bissau je pense
vraiment que le jour où les gens vont
comprendre qu'ils drouot québec c'est à
eux puis qu'on peut aider leurs rêves
communs et que les gens vont comprendre
qu individuellement en changeant leur
comportement ils vont des ae un matin
j'ai aidé hydro québec avait zéro point
et 2 kilowatts à gégé et d hydro québec
parce que c'est ça et aujourd'hui on
aperçoit des programmes d'efficacité
énergétique ça fait un petit peu
commerciale afin d'imiter rixe a fait
universitaire moi je veux interpeller le
coeur des québécois étaient ok at il
pire on l'a déjà fait dans le passé
écouté ce matin il fait vraiment froid
c'est qu'on peut tout vous servir mais
si vous me plaindre vous baisser d'un
degré vous venez de sauver au québec 250
millions cliquez embarque mouche sur 4
embarque luche sur du katanga est aussi
je suis sûr que tu embarques brahim par
ce boycott
on serait bien fou alors c'est c'est
comme ça qu'on voit se réapproprier les
hydro québec lequel les gens vont
comprendre qu individuellement ils ont
un pouvoir immense sur la création de
richesse pour eux parce qu'ils vont
avoir moins consommer mais aussi
collectives puis ça il ya au québec
qu'on peut faire ça parce que le
l'utilité publique nous à partir
on n'est pas en train d'enrichir un gros
pas new york qui disent non c'est enzo
on n'est pas la propriété de d'étrangers
si le chez nous maxime ans il ya des
milliers 610 milliards d'actifs je sais
c'est hallucinant je les fais la
consultation ce matin j'imagine que ça
va ça va aider à orienter la décision va
plaindre c'est une première c'est là que
c'est ça qu'on voulait donner du pouvoir
aux gens sur l'orientation stratégique
d'hydro-québec
attention les pieds trop gras thème
c'est l'économie verte la mobilité
durable puis dé façon de réinventer
commencé le 21 puis vous vous achetez
sur ses troupes on fait aussi trois
plaques sont importants dans le plan d'
le plan vert du gouvernement
le même plan pour une économie verte
mais nous on a un rôle à jouer important
dans ces trois axes loi parce qu'elle
sait et ses essais ses influences sa
consommation d'électricité
alors on veut comprendre ce que les
caisses qui était important pour les
gens parce que on peut même décider sous
20e étage la tour d'hydro-québec à
venelles avec à montréal les québécois
pensent quoi veulent quoi
et après ça on n'est pas fou à temps
plein ont plus long on est certain de
scission mais qu'est ce qui est vraiment
important pour les gens puis quel geste
peut-on poser qui vaille signifiant pour
les jeux mais tu sais moi j'ai répondu à
ce mes j paul et chief soumises the
innocent ce que je vois pas rennes
paraît difficile mais dans le fond vous
c'est vous c'est de sonder l'opinion
publique nam 1 % des cas c'est sans
délai ce que j'appelle le réflexe inné
ce qu'on va faire après ça c'est qu'on
voit là au dessus demi des idées afin
gpo midi
est ce que tu vas en mai je peux
vraiment me ouais mais c'est ça qu'il
faut mettre les idées aux folies mais
quand j'ai dit que l'on va se faire des
emprunts de trier six des leurs avec
intelligence artificielle péan l'on
regarde les thèmes au regard des régions
la pression va dire écoutez voici ce
qu'on ne reçu voici ce que ça implique
aimez-vous sauf si vous aimez ça voici
ce qu on vous suggère qu'on fasse bien
en 2022 relancer les projets puis pour
des petits projets des plus gros projets
un peu partout au québec qui vont
arrêter pensé demander soumis parlement
bien appuyé par hydro québec plutôt que
d'être le leader en énergie qui tirent
tout le monde sait qui on est on est
gros en et beck bon c'est autant
on veut à être le catalyseur de peau
chez nous c'est quoi ton rise puissions
les cas pas de t d ont voté dix ans
n'est pas capable dans le propos mais si
on est capable il faut juste qu'on le
sache
taiwo 6 47% transformer notre économie
pour qu'elle soit verte 26% à repenser
la mobilité pour la rendre durable puis
27% réinventer notre façon de consommer
l'énergie fait que je suis maso terme à
trois semaines d'économies qu'elle soit
bien je te donne un aperçu d'un chat ces
trois mauvaises ya pas de mauvaise
réponse d'un ballet l'excusé mois n a
fait qu on va faire parce qu'on
regardera pas sur ceux créés ces
résultats puis mots j'ai hâte de voir
dans les régions c'est un peu partout au
québec comme en ligne comme parce que
globalement je pense que globalement une
intuition le sens vraiment libre un
tiers un tiers un tiers
globalement je pense les patrons et
c'est pour ça qu'on fait d'ailleurs je
ne sais pas mais dans les régions je
pense que tu vois des géométries
variables fait mais l'idée c'est de
faire des affaires qui vont coller avec
la vie intelligente puis des affaires
qu'on va faire de manière parapluie là
de toute façon mon père on a tout un
bout du plan stratégique cette zone qui
va qui veulent décider parce que c'est
notre métier comment on construit ou est
ce qu'on construit comme en face au mans
mais mais sur le terrain les jeunes des
gens en cause qu'on voit le canton seize
mille idées ce parce que des gens ont 10
des noyaux loup dans le but de donner ce
qui m'apparaît depuis qu'on parle depuis
tantôt en fait par rapport à
l'efficacité énergétique une des cinq
majeur envers hydro québec c'est les
infrastructures énormes c'est l'énorme
projet qui venait s'implanter dans un
environnement qui était pas du tout fait
pour se douter qu'ils venaient saccagé
des bd des forêts puis des déplacés des
rivières des choses comme ça mais ce que
j'entends depuis tantôt en fait c'est
que si tout le monde est plus efficace
avec son énergie pickles par exemple les
instances gouvernementales subventionne
une transition vers des immeubles comme
si qui sont plus verte plus efficace
avec leur énergie
j'imagine que les projets
d'infrastructure deviennent moins
nécessaires ils sont reportés dans le
temps selon leur popularité assez solide
et figé c'est exactement ça alors il ya
des gens qui disent tout pigé mais c'est
exactement ça alors c'est certain on
peut pas dire qu'on a eu on ne put
besoin de moyens de production jamais
avis non mais c'est certain que à chaque
fois qu'on consomme mieux on reporte
dans le temps la nécessité surtout avec
une transition qui ça revienne qui va
nécessiter plus de lui oui mais ce qui
en a marre au calendrier un nouveau
projet à devoir âgées présentes on voit
pas ça à court et moyen terme mais il ya
des gens qui me disent ce qu'il est ce
que vous êtes qu'il n'avait jamais
jamais personne assise dans ma chambre
ce qui veut dire ce parce que parce que
je n'ai pas c'est à dire ceux de dans 50
ans il ya plus de pétrole on a besoin
d'électricité par la main que le québec
vouloir développer plus avant
l'hydroélectricité c'est possible en
même temps qu'elle va être qu'elles vont
avec les innovations technologiques qui
vont réduire métier 50 illégaux à 50 %
du bilan c'est des énergies fossiles au
québec eurent on va dire les offenses et
50 pour ça ce d'électricité en masse
donc donc on va faire et on utiliser
l'hydrogène pour une partie de chat qui
vous réquérir de l'électricité on va
avancer tout le monde là-bas mais
l'efficacité de tout pigé c'est
exactement ce qu'est ce qui va avoir
advenant le cas qui a des
des nouvelles infrastructures qui vont
être mis de l'avant j'imagine qu'il va
avoir peut-être le meilleur souci pour
pour l'endroit qui de l'endroit où
est-ce qu'ils comptent choisir la façon
de ces faits c'est aujourd'hui que des
lacunes comme un immense un immense plus
que des lacunes et des méchantes bull
c'est l'histoire de la baie james qui
est un succès sociologie des génériques
économique extraordinaire séné dans le
dans la colère et de la douleur d'un
peuple en paix puis aujourd'hui
hydro-québec fait beaucoup mieux avec
les communautés inouk on faisait avant
mais il reste tellement de chemin et
enfin on peut faire encore hydro québec
peut et doit faire beaucoup mieux avec
les communautés autochtones
on travaille avec les communautés mais
comment ce qu'on ne peut plus
d'autochtones dans nos rangs ça n'a pas
de bon sens catch merckx et les produits
touchés en fait c'est leur quotidien sur
un territoire donné chez eux ou avec ça
on est chez eux
absolument mettez ces il est des fois
que ceux des blessures consomme en
commun qu'on commet pas d'abord forte
écoute ses légendes et parce que moi je
me suis beaucoup exprimé là dessus que
c'est un souhait un voeu personnel très
fort d une des affaires que je voudrais
faire chez hydro bana que je suis là
aussi c'est de nous rapprocher des
communautés avec lesquelles on a plus de
difficultés historiques
si tu fais pas ça il ya un rythme soit
aussi tu peux pas bousculé puis moi je
crois beaucoup aux gestes composent plus
qu'aux paroles conti puis le geste
appuya pour moi c'est un geste concret
mais après ça te dit et à des gestes des
gestes de vite quand on parle des
embauches multicartes quand tu dis au
québec pourquoi on n'a pas plus de toc
toc aujourd'hui si tu veut postuler chez
hydro québec
tu rentres le site internet emploi tu
rentres dans des catégories tu postules
décrite au paragraphe ça s'envoie
cheminots facile
la bouteille un ordinateur c'est sa
faute à internet
il faut que tu parle français il faut
écrire français alors de plusieurs
communautés qui parle français mais ils
l'écrivent peau alors veut dire quoi ça
faisait qu'il faut que nous dans toutes
les relations doctrine qu'on nous
comprenne sur nous de dire à des jeunes
et des moins jeunes voici les emplois
qu'ils ont puis quand qu'on fasse
l'effort délibéré de créer quelque chose
spécifiquement pour rejoindre dans les
eaux plates
c'est d'aller sur place un autre affaire
une entreprise comme la nôtre d'être là
d'autres au sens non plus tant la langue
c'est une entreprise qui a la capacité
de prévoir sur des décennies alors par
exemple on a des lignes de 30 des
dizaines de milliers de kilomètres de
lignes de transmission électrique
pendant toutes ces lignes la faute du
contrôle la végétation
parce que si tu montres opposite bordel
alors une chose qu'on peut très bien
faire si ali dans différentes
communautés et d'écouté est ce que ça
vous tente
nous on clôt on l'a des contrats avis à
donner ici la facture des jeunes prenez
votre qu à limite tu peux te déplacer
que ministère de l'éducation par exemple
si on vous donnait un cours sur place
puis quand j'allais avoir vos cartes
partez-vous une business on va vous
engagez vous allez avoir de l'emploi on
va vous engager il y eut un métier pour
vous il y en a d'autres qui vont vouloir
faire autre chose faire de la
technologie pourquoi on prendrait peau
une partie des ddd d'hydro-québec qu'on
l'a centraliserait pas en région pour
une tâche donnée le technologies de
l'information puis quand on dirait pas à
des à des allochtones et autochtones
ben vous allez faire saut pour le québec
à partir de jeudi pour moi baie comeau
puis développé des jeunes des jeunes
autochtones avec des jeunes dans
allochtone mais face à partir de baies
comme ça c'est une idée ou c'est un
projet best du 10 large projet c'est
tout des affaires qui on veut faire mais
moi ce que je veux pas arriver cd mais
voici ce qu'on va faire ce que je veux
c'est que les communautés autochtones
nous disent qu'est ce qu'elles veulent
moi dans mon intuition lève le futur
c'est les jeunes c'est l'éducation puis
pansement l'instruction universitaire de
personnes mais qu'est ce que tu veux
faire dans la vie puis moi je fais des
stages chez hydro-québec on devrait être
capable de faire ça puis historiquement
quand quand hydro québec installé ce
qu'on appelle des carmes un lot pour
opérer ou pour construire mais on donne
des contrôles sur l'entretien ménager
avec les communautés autochtones qui
tous ont les moyens chef qui m'a dit
sereine et craint l'oms
madame ça serait bien que nos jeunes
fassent autre chose que de laver des
toilettes puits de miroir je te sens à
mon oeil aux raisons c'est correct de
laver des toilettes et des miroirs
laisse les jeunes autochtones se disent
il ya juste ce que à quoi j'ai axé sa
marche pas il faut que les jeunes
autochtones puissent penser alors bon
bref soucier une un des aspects
développer développer des entreprises
qui sont les leurs les a aidés avec
l'écrit c'est quand on regarde
air inuit la ccc née de la bonne idée en
temps de la baie james
ce sont des pilotes cris qui pilote un
avion d'hydro-québec com
comme tout le monde j'étais allé voir la
pièce
j'aime hydrologique est déjà entendue
par le pit et e
c'est un travail incroyable ses pieds
autant que c'est instructif que c'est
drôle que c'est bien fait que c'est que
c'est tout mais vraiment qu'ils
quitteraient raconte aussi la complexité
de t'choupi lalalalala des quelques
saignements soyez que ces points noirs
ou blancs mais il est quand même code il
reconstruit je te marquer communauté
autochtone qui lance le terrain
justement en parlant aux gens il ya
encore une place à la concentration au
centre de parler mais aussi a fait le
calcul à la frenchie du coût de
production du kilowatt heure pile du du
prix auquel on le 20 puis elle arrive à
la conclusion qui est presque passé des
potes déficit en baisse que son calcul
les fonctionne ou est ce qu'il sait
comment l'expliquer a fait son calcul
est pas mauvais maintenant il n'est pas
complet puisqu'on compte je crois que
convenu ensemble de faire c'est de faire
le prochain but pour vous pour fermer la
loupe
puis mais c'est ce vers garde fesf est
simple aujourd'hui la le coût marginal
de production d'hydro-québec est plus
grand que le coût moyen
ça veut dire en termes de la loi 15 à 5
ça coûte ça coûte en moyenne je vous
donner un chiffre mais tant que ça coûte
mettant à moyenne et c'est pas de sama
le brochet toujours de neige dès
maintenant en moyenne 400
d'approvisionner les québécois à la
marge on vienne signer six ou avec apu
est donc le le coût de l'installation
additionnel contagion est plus élevé que
le coût actuel donc par définition dès
que tu ajoutes des consommations
additionnel
tu vois les approvisionner à un coût
supérieur à celui du coût moyen est que
si tu poses ton raisonnement au bout on
arrête on consomme plus on nous fournit
plus on n'augmente pas la consommation
par chevaux marchent pas faux alors
quand tu regardes coût marginal de ton
de ton approvisionnements il faut que
ton prix de vente couvre un coût moyen
qui s'en vont croissant par définition
python coût marginal voit toujours est
croissant ap 8 qui coûte 6 ou est une
énergie intermittente coûte à peu près
même prix que la romaine qui est en
puissance qui est là tout le temps fait
il ya des comparaisons qu'il faut pas
tout a fallu faire avec toute la toute
la job diderot puis quand j'explique ce
six essais je trouve moi trop chaud ce
capital l'institut c'est ce qu'on
appelle le bilan énergie dollars et
d'hergé puissance dallara lors le bilan
s'est on commence par dire on est en
2021 peloton reprendre leur froc et nos
moyens de production
là on projette le pot 10 ans 15 ans 20
ans 30 ans 40 ans nos moyens existants
ce qu'on a en place
bon ils sont où c'est quoi la puissance
c'est quoi l'énergie
après cette période et on a des désirs
liens d'achat d'électricité éolienne
mais là tu mets tout seul en place sur
le territoire québécois
après ça tu modélise l'hydraulicité
parce que des années où il pleut des
années où il pleut pas il ya eu des
années où il reconnaît qu'un choc ça
fait pas si longtemps que ça parce qu'il
y avait moins d'eau dans les réservoirs
qui avait de la consommation tu peux pas
dire que les réservoirs sont vraiment
très riche en eau présentement on a
l'équivalent d'une consommation annuelle
du québec en arrière des barrages
beaucoup de fans mais ça serait pas
toujours comme ça tu as qui dissèque et
que tu m'as délice qui modélise le vin
comme dans l'hiver qu'on vient de passer
depuis et depuis quelques mois le
beaucoup moins ventyx ta rythme avec ton
éoliennes sur le tibet j'espère qu'elle
va venir là parce que on est un point
clé ya des éoliennes qui ont beaucoup
moins produit effectué modéliste au
chaud mais ce que je voyais les modèles
suivants
après ça tu vas même affaire avec la
demande ils ont été en 2021
voici la demande du québec depuis 10 15
ans les résidences les commerces les
industries des gros morceau ce qui est
plus difficile à modéliser parce que
c'est pour une aluminerie une grève
les parts du papier le segment que tu
dis les faisceaux des possibles de la
main qui l'a pas de chevaux m
le plan de transition énergétique ça va
se faire les autos sur quelle période
à quel moment plus tu fais des scénarios
éclatons faisceau de possibilités
d'offres de ton faisceau de possibilité
de demandes pilote ça ça se croisent
bleu tu dis quand je regarde saut à peu
près en 2026 2027 2028 avant de prendre
des moyens additionnels en énergie bonne
somme en puissance en puissance au
triple en europe ajoute donc on va faire
un appel d'offres en éoliennes hockey
plus quand tu regardes d'antan je suis
dit ok comment je vais à provisionner ce
quels moyens je vais déclenché bien
combien ça va me coûter le sommet des
éoliennes
je mets du soleil avant tommy de
l'efficacité énergétique vers baisse et
a couru tout avance dans le temps comme
ça et là tu vois que c'est la gestion de
l'optimal tc2 c'est l'option qu'il faut
qu'on se construisent au québec les
générations qui nous ont présentés qui
nous ont précédés et ombre au tibet est
plus grand que le besoin de l'époque on
était chanson vous dis pas ce que je
vais porter nos jardins alors qu'on
avait besoin d'une rivière c'est toute
la question de 10 le coût marginal das
comment s'y est ce qu'on a besoin c'est
sûr qu'on va avoir besoin de moyens
additionnels pour produire de
l'électricité
puis ces moyens-là savoir d'abord nous
dans notre consommation convoi baisse
ce conte si comme dû s'endetter un
barrage patrice evra est des batteries
qu'on va ajouter pour stocker quand on
ne peut pas besoin
ça va être des panneaux solaires ça sera
même pas des panneaux solaires dominique
ça va être quoi acheter une toiture et
dans la toiture
il va y avoir le système solaire
aujourd'hui on installe des panneaux par
dessus des toits sont tantôt sauvette
archaïque monde capable d'estimer dans
20 ans quelle va être notre consommation
d'énergie
on est capable de faire des scénarios en
cas de face et plus ou moins écoute
c'est le seul l'écart l'univers des
possibles très là
parce qu'elle sait pas ce qu'il faut
être fou mais ce fait que d'enfoncer
c'est le temps des prévisions mais parce
que c'est tellement des projets
d'envergure et nord il faut les amants
qui font les infos les amortir sur un
long temps mais faut aussi les prévoir
d'avancé en sa cliente
parce que tu te remets pas sur indices à
nancy lens 26 qu'ils ont un horaire
passera une semaine en disant ça prend
ça prend une leçon prochain les
éoliennes déjà vu notre fourmi qui voit
bien mais j'ai déjà vu une 1,3 que
passer avec des népal des pales des
liens à côté de moi puis quand ils
voient de loin on la petite passe quand
ça passe à côté de toi le c'est long un
si long comme un boeing
ouais sinon quand même passé à côté de
moi je ne sais pas c'est une des c'est
une des caractéristiques intéressantes
dans l'éolien c'est que j'aperçois
flexible et agile
as tu peux c'est pas un endroit du
territoire tu peux les dispersés sur le
territoire en fonction de coûts et la
charge puis c'est pas très long à
construire comparativement un grand
barrage à cravacher 15 20 ans des
éoliennes c'est plus court mais un grand
barrage il ya de la puissance
il ya de la réserve l'éolienne n'y en a
pas fait la magie de la magie de mme
angle qui font sushi brousse et c2c de
prévoir puis jerry la la la globalité
puis un loyer puis on n'a pas droit
quand on y pense on n'est pas loin de
manquer notre coup parce que la première
mission d'hydro-québec c'est d'assurer
la fiabilité du service b les gens
voudraient qu'on soit tout le temps tout
en sacoche puis tout le temps juste pas
trop change juste à temps c'est comme si
on partait
tout est roi loeb qui comprenait un
avion pour paris puis en atterrissant
paris le pilote disait écouter bienvenus
bienvenue à paris vii extraordinaire on
est arrivé il nous reste un demi-litre
de jet fuel en quarts lac tout le temps
on se serait attiré chez taillissime
souffrir à la map m il s'est acharné à
la c'est un long voyage fournit
l'électricité
tu parles tu peux pas être taxé la
responsabilité de construire à la vente
mais là il faut intégrer dans tous les
moyens la disposition d'hydro-québec
toutes les technologies qui s'en
viennent et de modéliser quel va être le
comportement des gens qu'on ne la
responsabilité de servais énergies en
commun
que voulez vous c'est solide et avec des
nouvelles technologies est-ce qu'il va
falloir revoir le nom d'hydro-québec
écoute moi je t'en as fait que je
reverrai pas ouais parce qu'il de la
marque hydro-québec dans le monde des
forains
moi ce que je pense là c'est que en fait
hydro québec c'est la seule entreprise
qui à tous les québécois comme clients
c'est la seule entreprise que tous les
tous les québécois comme actionnaire et
dans ses beaux tous les québécois qui
voient ça d'un bon oeil
j'accepte ces sacs et c'est là dessus
que je veux travailler comme une folle
parce que qu'est ce qu'ils voient pas
mais qu attendait un bébé moi parce que
parce que quelqu'un qui
c'est dire par exemple est un monopole
qui peuvent changer les prix qu'ils
savent être que si ça veut dire que ça
faisait quelques grammes un peu ça me
plaît pas ça veut dire que la farce et
puis on les entasse les réponses mais
mais mais mais mais quand on les entend
moi je vous les avancées conversation là
parce que non pas pour charger de tarifs
qu'on veut nous nos tarifs qui est
régulé présentement il ya une loi qui
est en place qui dit le trajet va
augmenter à l'inflation jusqu'en 2025 en
2025 la régie énergie vous regardez la
justesse des coûts encourus vous
rétablir le tarif pour voir si tout est
correct ou cinq ans waris est fait non
puis un monopole c'est un monopole tous
les ai toutes les actifs de distribution
ou d'électricité ou de gaz naturel à
travers le monde
ce sont des monopoles il faut que ce
soit régulée puis pourquoi ces des
monopoles ne peut pas mettre des lignes
de transmission des écrits de côte à
côte se paye pour fêter mes quatre
freins là où ggg katché quelque chose
j'ai compris quelque chose est cassé le
plus mais tout ça pour dire que quand
les gens ont l'impression que c'est
mieux que eux et l'argent dans leurs
poches plutôt que le gouvernement wallon
c'est loin d'un objectif
je vais vous donner un autre exemple
puisse en espèces de tabou dont on n'est
pas supposé parler et puisqu'on en
recense plus compté dans votre sens
jason de tous les tarifs d'électricité
des gens qui disent qui on est et tarifs
résidentiels les moins chers en amérique
nord ok on part de ce principe le moi je
vous soumettrai une tarification qui qui
qui sied aux riches
parce que si je suis riche que je
consomme beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup je
paie le même prix sur une base et le
kilowattheure la personne qui en
consomment peu je peux avoir une maison
accrochée ça monte à gaoua semaine un
chalet de ski à tremblant une maison je
mords du lac magog
puis mon électricité solaire allumé
quand je parle
non mais je peux avoir une patrie
d'aspach-le-haut femme je dis pas que
ces banques c'est pendant notre
tarification c'est pas tellement lent
tarifs comme tel c'est la manière dont
s'y est fait mal la manière dont le
tarif est fait si quelqu'un demande
beaucoup de puissance à l'intérieur de
son tarif toute la puissance dont je te
parle tant tout est pas dans le tarif
fait qu il ya une idée qui a flotté
pendant plusieurs années deux et on
devrait augmenter les tarifs
d'électricité au québec
envoyez des crédits d'impôts à ceux qui
sont pas capables de payer
d'augmentation puis de charger le prix
de ce que ça vaut puis que les riches
qui consomment beaucoup moins et générer
plus de revenus au gouvernement
mais là les gens disent ou au menu menu
tu vois tu la vois le break du
gouvernement et que j'ai mon temps à
voir le tarif par jour dans ma poche qui
moindre revenu au gouvernement
enfin politiquement c'est compliqué non
pas de l'énergie la selo aider
politiquement c laude et socialement
mais quand tu penses à ce tu veux comme
consommateur comme actionnaire avoir un
signal de prix qui va te faire faire la
bonne affaire
tout ce que touche que je discute avec
vous autres depuis tantôt en disant je
veux hydro-québec déployer des mesures
je vais payer 300 quelqu'un pour qu'ils
consomment mieux mais si le tarif était
juste un petit peu plus élevée tu
consommerait moins chaud que de payer
pour l'argent rentre au gouvernement
je conçois comme il se fait et si tard
en europe
mais vous l'avez vu le titre en vo dans
les hôtels en europe il fait noir là
dedans ça pas de bon sens en partant
d'ascenseur la lumière ou ford ascenseur
la lumière ferme tu arrives dans le
corridor la numéro sur en entachant la
lumière captée dans fais pas ta carte
pour ma tante à ce lot pour le pauvre ça
coûte cher mais ça vaut chat là on n'est
pas en train de partir la mouvance dans
l'hydro québec va augmenter ses tarifs
c'est pour ça que je dis mais ce que je
dis c'est que tout
dante autant je disais tantôt tu peux
pas avoir une énergie propre
renouvelable tout le temps disponible
peu cher cela ça n'existe pas il ya
toujours un coup aux choix qu'on fait
puis ce sont des choix qui sont
fondamentaux pour la suite des choses
puis le boulot d'hydro-québec c'est de
faire en sorte que on va être là pour
approvisionner le québec le faire le
moins cher possible
mais j'ajoute achement de là la
nécessité d'expliquer comment ça marche
est-ce que ça l'a déjà été discutée un
tarif qui augmenterait selon la
consommation
il ya des tarifs en inde il ya des
tarifs qu'on appelle progressif mais sur
la sur la base mayme parce que c'est la
puissance c'est comme une industrie plus
quelqu'un consomme un niveau d'énergie
stable plus son tarif est faible en
industriel parce que vous le devez à
l'agacer c'est encore une fois c'est les
pics l'on assiste effrayant ça coûte la
peau des fesses ça coûte vraiment rachat
et c'est pour ça que c'est pour ce
qu'hydro québec avait fait un tarif bi
énergie sur l'île de montréal
en fait partout au québec mais notamment
sur l'est de montréal mais ils l'ont
jamais expliqué
quand ils ont dit on lève le secret
c'est comme on est en train de
travailler avec avec énergie à la
demande du gouvernement puis il fait
bien sûr au québec on a en eu deux
grands réseaux de distribution
électrique un grant deux grands réseaux
distribution énergétique en électricité
et en gaz naturel des infrastructures
saddam que hydro québec appartient au
gouvernement puis nrj l'actionnaire
majoritaire sa caisse des dépôts fait
quelque part on est proche de ce qu'on
veut électrifier davantage les bâtiments
aujourd'hui ses battements là il y en a
cinq mail qui sont à gaz naturel
pourquoi parce que le gaz naturel coûte
moins cher que s'ils gardent naturel et
de chats il serait électrique
le gaz naturel est moins chaud puis ça
va être comme ça prend des buts
il est comme ça les gens sont allés trop
de gaz naturel mais on veut que les
bâtiments réduisent leurs émissions de
gaz à effet de serre alors comment on
fait ça avec comme on est des joueurs
appelons chaque os à enghien puis qu'on
est dans le mieux-être collectif
on s'est assis ensemble quand et du
comment au faisceau alors l'idée c'est
que sciemment énergie va travailler avec
les délégués commerciaux d'hydro-québec
pour dire aux clients car la fournaise
arrive à durée de vie utile vous à les
transporter pour vos volumes de gaz
naturel en base à l'électricité mais on
va garder la pointe à gaz nature fait
qu'on fait qu'on va réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre parce
qu'ils vont consommer soixante dix pour
cent moins de gaz naturel ils vont
passer l'électricité mais on prendra pas
la charge de points on va la laisser au
gaz naturel fiction était jusqu au
boutiste qu'on disait il faut plus qu'à
y est d'ailleurs naturel faut piquer
l'énergie fossile
d'abord les gens viendraient peau parce
que ça coûte chaque fois qu'il ya une
démarche commune pour inciter les
clients avant le bon comportement
puis à prestation a vu que ce soit au
moindre coût possible parce que ces
tarifs allemands
on va en amener encore moins parce que
ça va coûter encore plus cher dans
l'année fait l'intelligence l'on sait
mettre nos énergies
1 comment je reviens là dessus le spo
pornic ça s'appelle de même parce que
c'est l'énergie comme tel les bété eu
mais c'est l'énergie humaine c'est
l'énergie financière puis c'est orient
dès qu'il faut tout comme un tout petit
morceau ensemble et nos petits morceaux
ensemble on va réussir
puis c'est ce qui vaut faire en sorte
qu'on va faire sans mettre un coup est
dur à l'économie change de sujet le jeu
c'est qu'ils avaient soumissionné pour
la prison à proville approvisionner une
partie de la ville de new york en
énergie mais que fait mettre des bâtons
dans les roues par certaines
campagne américaine même temps est-ce
que ces dossiers là je l'on attend d'une
entrevue voulait un mois ou scud
semblait très irrité par la situation
est-ce que ça allait bouger ou deux
projets chat il ya un projet le projet
de new york c'est le projet le plus
récent du qu'il ya un projet maine
massachusetts
alors en 2018 hydro québec a signé avec
le massachusetts un contrat
d'exportation
le mas a été un des premiers et aux
dents nord-est américain à se donner des
objectifs très très rigoureux et très
ambitieux de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre dans ce conte l
dumont d'électricité fait à partir de
centrales qui utilisait à l'époque du
mazout et du gaz menace et surtout du
gaz mais c'est des centrales qui cinq
utilise l'énergie fossile ou bien aux
autres leur objectif c'est que leur
électricité soit décarbonés très
rapidement donc hydro-québec un signe un
contrat 2018 maintenant l'autre un
client massachusetts
ça prend de la hauteur de l'eau je fais
une longue histoire courte il ya un as à
travers le maine ya un partenaire qui
est centrale mène pas loin pour
construire la ligne float en bacs dans
un processus réglementaire fait d'abord
tu gagnes un appel d'offres ok il ya
beaucoup de monde là dessus cette
impression d'un processus réglementaire
33 au mot on a reçu tous les permis le
dernier ça s'appelle le permis
présidentielle pour commencer à
construire et beaucoup de gens qui
veulent de l'hydroélectricité du québec
il ya des gens qui en veulent pour ceux
qui en veulent pas c'est ce qu' au par
des centrales de production
d'électricité à gaz naturel aux états
unis parce que là bas gens qui ont un
modèle d'affaires qui a copié mais mais
moi moche mais ce préposé aux états unis
dans le massachusetts a décidé qu'il
n'avait plus de 600 trains de la fin mai
aux autres et qui ont combattu le
massachusetts
ils n'ont pas réussi macha tout ça te
faisant appel d'offres il savait pas et
enzo s'arrête une autre entreprise de
production d'électricité renouvelable
qui aurait gagné mais ça aurait été
moins par rapport aux autres parce que
s'arrêter de l'éolien ou du solaire qui
est intermittent pilote toujours besoin
d'une campagne
la centrale exactement vous avez tout
pigé alors là que le doute on arrive on
y va on est concurrentiel on hello tout
le temps fatigué tex et aux autres qui
elles sont très agressifs plomb les taux
aux etats-unis puis moi je découvre un
paysage où plusieurs ça se compare pas
de vue la politique américaine
exactement alors le zoo ils financent
des groupes qui se disent
environnementalistes pour dire que c'est
effrayant que ce soit hydro québec puis
là il attaque la manière dont on
construit dans notre partenaire
construit la ligne de transmission que
toute pensée les autorisations
environnementales que les autorités du
mannequin alors ces gens là ils lancent
des cocos lance de cocody ont initié un
référendum on s'envoie référendum
environnementalistes qui rajoute
hydro-québec au mais financée par métier
accepte l'argent d'une centrale parce
que ces pays côte est une technique il
ya ils ont deux trois compagnes et la
nymphe une technique connue l'an fait un
extérieur elle l'a fait en californie
ils perdent ils perdent appel d'offres
ils perdent le projet fait qu'ils y
perdent ils essayent d'attaquer le
projet sur processus réglementaire puis
quand ça marche pas là il s'en vend pays
vont mobiliser du monde plaisir offert
un référendum etc ce que ça fait le
projet avait fini par se faire mais
coûte beaucoup de chats nous est
beaucoup plus long que pendant sa vie
continue d'opérer lyon était
extraordinaire n'est que travail ont été
trouvés d'ailleurs coupable parce que il
ya des gens qui voulaient développer des
mesures d'efficacité énergétique en
floride ont affleuré des mesures
d'efficacité énergétique à fleur de peau
tant d'autres dépôts autant sauter quand
parce qu'il vend de l'électricité la
bobby's dix mots je veux mon beau
tableau entre deux philosophies alors il
était content les mesures d'efficacité
énergétique
puis il était content parce que les gens
disaient faut que je sois la compagnie
qui assume ça parce que quand tu
consomment moins d'électricité ton
tarifs par unité théoriquement augmente
ok parce que moins compenser de la même
coupe de moins qu'au moins de volume
pour les ventes est foutue venture
alors en extérieur voulais pas ça les
gazaouis ont convaincu un groupe de gens
de peau noire de s'opposer à sa guise et
saas avec mauvais pour les noirs qui ont
financé le groupe lo les gens savaient
pas trop pourquoi il s'oppose et devrait
pas trop vous invite à l'année ils
étaient manipulés complètement manipulé
puis en extérieur été trouvé coupable de
centre comme en bref c'est assez c'est
malheureux mais c'est sûr fait que oui
ça mérite sa mère maudit parce que il ya
des entreprises qui sont dans le domaine
des énergies fossiles qui sont très
progressiste puis qu'ils sont en train
de se développer
puis notre mec qui développe le gaz
naturel renouvelable qui mérite d'être
encouragé puis il ya en ont fait un gros
bannu et gagnent des énergies fossiles
comme il met ses deux trois compagnes
extrêmement puissant expérience et une
longue puisqu'elle pas une aussi
puisqu'elle pas une femme en maudit
parce que un de leurs grands
actionnaires dans les fonds de pension
canadien le fonds de pension canadien
bah ils placent l'argent des canadiens
dans une compagnie qui qui frappent
indûment une autre compagnie canadienne
qui essaye de faire juste de
l'exportation d'énergie renouvelable
demandé par un état exc donc c'est ça
avec la new york sa note a fait bloc
là il ya des le projet de ligne déjà est
déjà autorisée il reste à le construire
dont on ne souvient 9 mai 2009 à un prix
qui fait sens pour le québec presqu'en
comprendre le besoin au québec fecq
faucon faucon la vendre à un prix qu'il
est intelligent pour nous qu'il faut
faire en sorte que ça va être mieux de
façade argent la pile de réutiliser dans
les coffres québécois pour faire
d'autres choses que de prendre cette
électrice elop la transformer chez nous
c'est toujours le fendant même si vous
aimeriez travailler chez nous
si vous n'êtes pas de castor si on met
en oeuvre on note deux youtuber
maintenant prenez des jeunes tombés loin
thomas pison
bon bah ouais ouais on s'est dit il faut
qu'on parle ont montré qu on engager de
telles que tous quand tout ce qu'on a
dit depuis tantôt des choses qui ne
seraient pas concernés puis que je faire
j'avais quelques membres qui sont
beaucoup et non plus 2 qui nous écoutent
échec est un bon ça simplement direction
écoute c'est assez c'est fascinant
encore une fois
moi j'invite tout le monde à vous
rapprocher
hydro-québec pinottes boulot c'est de se
rapprocher de tout le monde
mehdi visuellement et en s'ancrant dans
les différentes communautés
c'est sur le boulot mon fils c'est le
rêve que j'ai de mon passage chez drew
c'est que c'est que un jour l'automne
calotte et les et qu'un jour tu as une
calotte juste avec ce qui semble un plus
non mais c'est sont belles c'est pas
donc je répète à partir de 6 ans venait
pékin tu parlais de la marque
hydro-québec temps a ajouté ahmad et
nike qui a le plus besoin d'écrire micky
sur sa balle je serai petit crochet un
hydro québec a mon avis tu as même
plateau shabbat accrochés 3-6 la marque
la marque et la marque est bonne merci
merci merci je l'aï vraiment fait que
céder beau défi qui quittent attend
quand même blagué nous attend depuis
quand une équipe est une grande équipe
mais ouais c'est ça ça fait mal mais il
a maintenant quelqu'un qui nous écoute
qu'il veut
qui veut
s'informer plus ou imaginent apprendre
plus sur l'efficacité énergétique
comment je me suis donc dit oui puis si
vous voulez commencer quelque chose de
l'fun
je retiens tu énergies en commun points
c'est à aller lire là dessus répondez au
sondage
si vous avez des idées n'importe quel
n'y a pas d'idées folles écrivait l'est
écrivait lanoux puis on va faire quelque
chose avec
puis rappelez de question ne s'est pas
terminée parce que tu es on a parlé tout
au long de ce podcast de réduire la
consommation d'énergie mais c'est quoi
ton
concrètement les actions les plus
faciles puis qui ont le plus grand
impact sur la réduction mais tant qu un
citoyen moyen pour faire de façon de la
consommation c'est pas juste la
consommation de thon électricité en
ouvrant et toute la consommation que tu
fais tous mes points jusqu'au moins
concernée ou consommer conscient de ce
que tu fais puis s'est hissée en livre
ici un livre dit pas qu'elle est oui ça
aussi c'est pâques elle est là ils sont
pas tout électrique encore le rex il ya
des entreprises qui ont des véhicules
électriques mais quitte charge une pièce
et demi de plus pour les britons petit
paquet si tu es capable de payer la
pièce feuilleton type akm pièces et
demie n'hésitez pas capable ce correct
mais tous sont là aussi tu t'es bon gars
du bourgeois faire venir surprise une
prochaine je vois faire venir l'autre
afin d'en venir toute la fin en même
temps parce quelqu'un mais on va venir
deux fois c'est tout yahia j'étais
justement avec thomas dans un engin pas
de casse en début de semaine puis il
disait j'ai de l'espoir comme jeune cas
les grandes entreprises vont nous faire
leur part c'est totalement faux que
chacun de nous fassions ne pas faut que
chacun de nous comprenions c'est notre
téléphone le téléphone intelligent lui
s'est chargé d'énergie sur le symbole
c'est pas l'électricité quand wade est
restée quatre caennais khl mais si
chargé d'énergie le tous les matériaux
qui vont les mains toute la technologie
est là depuis c'est c'est correct c'est
le femme c'est une bonne idée le change
à 12 mois au moins
super gt gt vraiment ravie de faire
votre connaissance à bout 3 c'est quand
il y en a qui parlent pas tout
est-ce que tu as quitté une question tu
veux ajouter tatouage est à même nom en
fait j'ai
non aux riches j'ai pas pensé à mon
avatar sauté dans ma vie je penserai à
l'orgue merci beaucoup
j'ai passé un bon moment merci merci
d'abord écouté ses podcasts jusqu'à la
fin de ce pas que vous avez apprécié la
conversation ça prouve que vous êtes de
réelles fans de conversation et sans fil
pas de casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passe bien sûr peut
tuer a non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde pictural où
est ce que on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation convient d'abord
parce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on abordés pendant
le podcast donc allez sur une page de
turenne les liens vers ses avoirs dans
la description du podcast qui remercie
encore une fois nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fonte